Õpetaja: Nii päeva teine video.
Õpetaja: Ee share I
Õpetaja: ee. Kuhu me jäime? Me jäime vist siis kuhugi, sinna, et meil on Lihtsalt see tabel olemas. Aga ei ole andmetega. Rääkisingi seda, et nüüd on siis ee,
Õpetaja: ee, see koht kust, ee. Kas kellegil ei ole Veel see Karli tuli. Vahetunni ajal küsis. Vaata, et kuidas nagu näha. Seda pilti ja kõike neid teenuseid ja asju, et ette saada, Kas Kõigil on selline pilt endal ees.
Õpetaja: Mainis, et Andruse andruse käest tuli küsima. Andrus ei teadnud mõhkugi, kuidas see asi nagu äkki saada Tubli, Vaata, sa oled ühe sammuga kallist ees. Vaata, nagu, et. Okei, mul on mingi küsimus.
Õpetaja: I know the guide.
Õpetaja: Ee, põhimõtteliselt. Ee. Meil on nüüd vaja vaadata seda teenust. Ee, mida me siis peame kasutama? Selle tahaks lahti teha. Rääkisime pikalt ja laialt sellest ee koeri parameetrist või Request Parameetrist. Siin on lihtsalt nime. Parameeter. Hea lapse. Mitu nime see on? Siis? Lihtsalt sisend, mis läheb teenusele kaasa?
Õpetaja: Ta ei määra ära, Mida käivitatakse määral
Õpetaja: Ee. Meie võtame siis selle ette. Ee, ja meil on siis vaja hakata seda Teenust. Defineerima. Kus Me seda kasutada soovime,
Õpetaja: on loomulikult selles Atm s vaatajas. Kui teha nüüd jälle see lahti. Ja Kõigepealt template. Võime korra nagu eest ära tõmmata,
Õpetaja: et ee, meil Praegu tuuakse ära Citys andmed vastatajale.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha, niimoodi et ee, tuuakse ära ka.
Õpetaja: Tuuakse. Ära ka ühtlasi Locations andmed
Õpetaja: selleks. On meil vaja midagi, mis ee niiöelda siis ee, pöördub. Niiöelda sõnumina Ee, meie süsteemist ja teise süsteemi poole. Mis mõtted teil on, Kus mida peaks toimetama.
Õpetaja: Hetkel meil pole niikuinii midagi käivitada. Midagi pole veel niiöelda
Õpetaja: Ee, välja kutsuda. Sellepärast, et meil puudub niiöelda tehniline võimekus saata päringut niiöelda Backendile, et seda tahakski teha, Et
Õpetaja: hakkame seda osa programmeerima, Et me saadame Backendile sõnumi. Mis on teie mõte
Õpetaja: Tsau Services, onju Me Siiamaani Oleme juba kaks korda teinud logimist. Oleme teinud sisselogimist. Oleme teinud ee,
Õpetaja: ee, linnade äratoomist. Pole siin midagi muud erinevat kui Services. Kas siin On mingi teenu? Mingisugune fail mille alla võiks. Ee, see Ee location. Ee, Niiöelda andmete pärimine minna.
Õpetaja: Aga miks,
Õpetaja: Miks City Service alla peaks minema, kui ma nagu tulen otsima midagi, mis on seotud Locationiga. Mul tuleks elu sees selle peale. Mul on võõras inimene, et minna City Service alla vaatama, et City Service võiks tegeleda. Selliste asjadega on nagu linnade äratoomine uue linna Lisamine admin. Näiteks lisada, onju
Õpetaja: muutmine. Kustutamine peaks Uus D
Õpetaja: uusi fail.
Õpetaja: Noh, Location Service võiks ee, nimi olla.
Õpetaja: Väldiks. Seda mitmost mina väldiks, nagu. Aga me räägime entiti kui üks, nagu andmetüüp nii öelda, siis pigem ainsus. Minu meelest on nagu alati parem
Õpetaja: Location Service.
Õpetaja: See on kõige esimene, asi, mida me teeme ja miks, Miks see vajalik on,
Õpetaja: et teised Näeks Seda saaks sisse importida.
Õpetaja: Kes need kooliosad saaks siin toimetada? Tahame Siin defineerida uut Ee, meetodit. Alustame meetodi nimest.
Õpetaja: No saame natukene inspiratsiooni
Õpetaja: Jälle siit. Oleme teinud, et see meetod on hästi tehniline, et ta peegeldab põhimõtteliselt meil seda piiblit,
Õpetaja: no Mis võiks? Olla selle nimi? Meetode nimi Siin Get Locations. Jah,
Õpetaja: et oleks aru saada, et tegemist on sõnumiga. Siis Requestri nagu viitab sellele Ee, ketopäring. Ja põhimõtteliselt peegeldame seda urli. Ee, võibolla isegi panna mitte Locations, vaid panna Atm Locations.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see on osa urlist.
Õpetaja: Minu Muster on niimoodi api, Nagu võtab sellest välja, et tuleb kett Atm Locations Ja see on sõnum.
Õpetaja: Kuidagi nii Jällegi See nüüd ei ole Niimoodi, Kuidas igas arenduses maamunal tehakse, vaid see lihtsalt arhitektuuriline otsus, nagu
Õpetaja: mulle meeldib, Nii meie tiimile meeldib. Nii,
Õpetaja: kui te hakkate oma projekti tegema. Siis Teil on ka valikuvabadus. Kuidas te asjadega teete? Ja Mina ei tule teile. Ütle ette ütlema. Tingimata küll, aga lihtsalt, mida ma ütleks, siis iga keel on see, Kui ma näen, et üks inimene teeb ühtepidi ja teine teistpidi, siis teie tiim tegelikult ei tee seda asja korrektselt. Te peate ise kokku leppima. Ikkagi mingites tavades
Õpetaja: Ei, igaüks ei tee mingisugust oma.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kett Atm Locations. Neid on mitu, on ju.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on nüüd tavapärane värk. Vaata, et kuidas me. Sest et see see koodilõik käivitub Brauseris. Kuidas ta saab Frauserist saata sõnumi
Õpetaja: Browser It on sisse ehitatud. Fetch api, aga seda me ei kasuta. Kasutame aktsiast, mis on selle peale ehitatud,
Õpetaja: mis annab meile kõik need Trenn ja Catch Blokid ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: No siin on juba küsimus, et millist meetodit siit välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Veelgi parem oleks seda protsessi teha niimoodi sellisel kujul, et et minu ekraanilt võite vaadata, siis piibel hakkab ülevalt tulema. Niimoodi, vasakult paremale.
Õpetaja: No mis, mis meetodid võiks käivitada Get.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vaatame, mis sisendeid ta ootab, tootab kahte sisendit Urli. Ja siis mistahes konfirgatsioone.
Õpetaja: Rulli osas peaks olema suht lihtne Ankett Locations,
Õpetaja: et siin Lihtsalt Paneme siis stringi
Õpetaja: üldse külaga omad. Siit saab isegi Copida. Seda päris vägeres. Minu meelest ei saa. Pole kindel mitte proovida. Pärast
Õpetaja: me Sinnamaani jõuame minu isa isaakupi. Ta võib käsitsi ka kirjutada. Pole Midagi väga keerulist.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin on esimest korda. Meil Nüüd tuleb ühe korra. Me oleme varem kasutanud, kui me tahtsime manipuleerida seda, et heederis öeldakse Stoplight Ile, et mida ma preföörin vastusena
Õpetaja: Ee, siis kasutasime objekti. Ee, Nüüd on meil ee reaalne põhjus, miks meil on seda vaja kasutada. Seda parameetri asja. Seda saaks teha niimoodi. Ka. Ma panen ise siia Urli küsimärgi kirjutan. Ee City.
Õpetaja: Id pöördub ja nüüd siia liidakse mingisuguse muutuja City Id,
Õpetaja: et idee järgi saaks nii ka teha, sest kokku tuleb tegelikult selline string. Ja see sõnum läheb teele. No, see väärtus peaks kuskilt mujalt olema, on ju? Aga, ee, minu mõte on seda Teha küll, aga mitte niimoodi,
Õpetaja: vaid meil on siin siis selle jaoks eraldi olemas see objekt. Näed, see teine parameeter, mis on vabatahtlik küsimärk on seal olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame seda tüüpi. Siin on String. Siin on mingi Axios Request config, millele see viitab suurte tähtedega tegemist, on Mingi klassiga, järelikult. Mis siia sisse sobib?
Õpetaja: Mingisugune objekt Meil on siis mingi objekt vaja luua? Kuidas Me saame kõige lihtsamal viisil luua ja uue objekti
Õpetaja: ja kohe automaatselt tekib uus objekt.
Õpetaja: Ta juba pakub siin. Mingeid asju. Ma panen escape vaid. Ta on, ee, enter all, et saaks siia niimoodi allapoole tulla.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, siin on igast erinevad. Ee, niiöelda väljad selles objektis, mis sobivad nüüd kontrollitühikuga. Ma vaatan, mis ta pakub,
Õpetaja: pakub siin igasuguseid parameetreid, mis meile võiks sobida.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame oma piiblit Get Url,
Õpetaja: tuleme uuele reale. Mis siin on?
Õpetaja: Nii?
Õpetaja: Kas Jäi midagi silma Juba keegi hüüdis.
Õpetaja: Näete seda siin? Jah Params.
Õpetaja: Params.
Õpetaja: Mis see tähendab meie jaoks Mitmust, Mis mitmes meie jaoks koodilõigus tähendab Skopi Scoop. Meie jaoks tähendab
Õpetaja: bingo. Kõik Näed, siin Info on kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: No, ta juba tahtis siia midagi panna Jälle kogemata, sest et Ta avas selle menüü. Ma nagu kustutan selle ära.
Õpetaja: Nii kui me vaatame praegult seda Ee, teie vaadake. Siin ongi, et on, Ee, Sorry Ongi, et on. Worl
Õpetaja: On Url. Läheme uuele. Reale On Params
Õpetaja: on params. No see on Jaavascripti objekt. Nüüd siin peab jälle tulema mingi Key Value. Nüüd peab tulema Mingisugune Key ja mingisugune value.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sama üle ülesehitus, mis ma siia kirjutan. Nüüd
Õpetaja: City Id. Kui see on midagi keerulisemat. Kui Niukene asi, siis parem on see otse Svägerist. Lihtsalt, ee copida Aga, noh, see on nagu, mingi lihtne onju, et et Siin ma seda ei teeks, aga muul ajal vältige vigu. Pigem copy based iga kui vähegi on keerukust.
Õpetaja: Või siis olge ülihoolas nagu nendel kohtadel. Sest kui sind ei vea, siis ee, see sõnum. Kui mina. Panen need kogemata Näiteks niimoodi City Id,
Õpetaja: siis see saadab selle sõnumi. Ee, Backend näeb. Ära vaata seda, et tuli. Ja Backendil on olemas kaardistus kõikidest teenustest mis seal, on? Ta näeb, et sa tahtsid sellele saata, aga tema ootas parameetrid sisse. City Id. Suure Ga. Aga sina saatsid väiksega.
Õpetaja: Siis ütleb Fad Request.
Õpetaja: Ma tean, et sa tahad seda ühte teenust kasutada. Ma Isegi näen, et see on olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole sellisel viisil nagu kontrakt ette näeb,
Õpetaja: et Niukene värk, et Mitte vigu teha. Muidu aja on jälle vaata otsida. Kus see viga on?
Õpetaja: Nüüd sa ikka nii kooloniga saan talle väärtust anda.
Õpetaja: Noh, esialgu võib selle nulli siia sisse kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Nagu siin see näide see on.
Õpetaja: Aga me ju ometi ei taha teha endale niukest nimelist koodilõiku, mis toob ära ainult kogu aeg sellise sisendiga.
Õpetaja: Sellise sisendiga, nagu sõnumi saadab teele.
Õpetaja: Meil on nüüd vaja kuidagi seda asja siin natukene modifitseerida, et See asi tuleks dünaamiliselt sisse. Mitte
Õpetaja: kirjutatud siia koodi sisse.
Õpetaja: See võib olla üks, võibolla kaks ja võibolla kolm. See peab kogu aeg muutuma Vastavalt vajadusele,
Õpetaja: mida me saame teha oma koodis,
Õpetaja: Et seda olukorda siis teha? Selliseks, et siin see paindlikkus oleks olemas?
Õpetaja: No kui ma ütlen Seda Vaata, jällegi on see. Vaata, et küsimus on see, et kuskilt peab tulema info. Meie mängumaa on hetkel põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: siin maal ja pluss Kõik asjad, mis on väljaspoolt nii või naa kättesaadavad.
Õpetaja: Hetkel ongi küsimärk, et nagu et mingi väärtus peaks seal tulema iga kord erinev
Õpetaja: kuidas Me saame konstrueerida selle oma meetodi selliselt.
Õpetaja: Te peaksite ikkagi Miks teil. Miks teil siia niivõrd palju raskusi tekitab? Koguaeg, Ma ei saa aru sellest.
Õpetaja: Meil on mingi info, mis peab siia sisse tulema. Kuhu
Õpetaja: sinna? Ee request. Ee, suur aa ketta
Õpetaja: No sa rääkisid nagu õigeid, asju, Aga
Õpetaja: mingi mõte on. Aga kas keegi teine lihtsalt ütleb siis välja, Kui juba sai aru, mida meil on vaja selle meetodiga teha, see Meetod ei tea oma välisest elust kuidagi ööd ega mütsi. Kui me soovime, et Kas oleks mingit informatsiooni olemas siin sellel hetkel kui see Kood käivitub.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja lihtsalt ühte parameetri silti, et see on. Kus me defineerime Koodilõigu, mis käivitub. Kui Me tahame, et siia tuleks Iga kord mingisugune suvaline, erinev info. Vaatepil, numbri kujul
Õpetaja: Siis sa pead lihtsalt lisama parameetri,
Õpetaja: et kui keegi kutsub seda välja, no ma teen selle väljakutse siia samma. Näiteks mina tahan kutsuda välja seda meetodit, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee atm
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa isegi praegu seda kirjutada niimoodi sellisel viisil. Ma panen lihtsalt niimoodi. Mina tahaks seda meetodit kuskil mujal välja kutsuda. Siis minu mõte on see et mina, annan selle numbri kaasa,
Õpetaja: on ju iga kord meil on täpi pealt sama teema.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on vaja mingit sisendit siin, siis me loome lihtsalt selle jaoks võimekuse Kirjutada sisse Parameetri
Õpetaja: siia me ei kirjuta. See on. See on sildikene. Me ei kirjuta seda Ee, selliselt välja. Aga te võite mõelda jaavascriptis Led. Ja nüüd on vaja mingisugust nime, mis võiks olla selle sissetuleva sildikese nimi sissetuleva info?
Õpetaja: City Id. Noh, tavalise kohaliku muutaja loomine käib niimoodi Let
Õpetaja: City Id. Aga me tahame seda sama asja panna Siia,
Õpetaja: et on meil sildikene. Meil see need saab, sisse tulles käivitada, siis Seda sõna letti pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja nüüd
Õpetaja: meie, meie see meetodid ja oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi, mitte midagi, aga ta ei peagi teadma.
Õpetaja: Kui mul on siin selleks tegemiseks mingit infot vaja,
Õpetaja: siis ma loon selle võimekuse lihtsalt andes luues parameetrid.
Õpetaja: Parameeter seda meetodit on võimalik käivitada koos mingi infoga.
Õpetaja: No nii,
Õpetaja: ee,
Õpetaja: Nüüd kus on natukene kogemust juurde tulnud ja arusaamist, palun vaadake need videod uuesti üle,
Õpetaja: Need On küll, jaava näitel ongi hea. Me peame vaikselt jaavat ka mõtlema. Varsti hakkame jaavat ka natukene. Võibolla katsuma
Õpetaja: Mis asja läheb kui vaatad ja videosid. Ja pole vahet. Kontseptsioon,
Õpetaja: parameeter, parameeter, meetod. Imeline asi, Miks et me saame seda välja kutsuda kuidas me saame seda välja kutsuda objekti abil. Natukene kirjaviis. Ühtepidi teistpidi. Aga ma ütlengi. Praegult on nagu see. Ma istume nagu selles kohas, kus ma.
Õpetaja: Noh, oleme nüüd siin Nädal pluss oleme nagu toimetanud. Vaata, onju, et meil tegelikult peame hakkama aru saama seda, et meetodid on imelised koodilõiged. See on definitsioon, seda On võimalik käivitada. See ei ole see koht. Vaata, kus kutsume välja midagi. Siis me lihtsalt ütleme, et nagu siin on niuksed tegevused,
Õpetaja: et Ee, too too. Punane pliiats. Punane on see sisend. Too sinine pliiats.
Õpetaja: Too kollane pliiats. Too must pliiats. Mis iganes, too midagi on tegevus nimi.
Õpetaja: Sisend kaasa, mis? Mul on selleks tegevuseks vaja.
Õpetaja: Värv kolor.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: too pliiats on meetodi nimi. Kolor on parameeter. Siis meil ongi see, et, Ee, see, ee too pliiats. Nagu ei pea teadma muudest asjadest mitte midagi. Ta lihtsalt peab teadma ainult seda, kuidas pliiats ära tuua, Aga milline pliiats? Näiteks selles kontekstis.
Õpetaja: Palun vaadake need videod uuesti üle. Ee, need materjalid. Videod Üritage. Mõelda nendele asjadele, et see peab tegelt hakkama. Teil vaikselt juba tulema. Võib Olla lihtsalt ei julge pakkuda.
Õpetaja: Mulle Päev Vist läheb ka kuidagi kurjemaks, kuigi ma seda ei taha teha, Tahaks tegelikult olla teiega Niuke
Õpetaja: Nunnu, Niukene mõnna ja armas. Aga lihtsalt ongi nagu see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: tead, kuidas juhtub? Jah, no vaata, kui Muud moodi ei saa Siis ma kui te ei lõpeta seda jama Vaata, ei ütle, siis ma hakkangi tegema, niimoodi, et ee,
Õpetaja: kõik ülejäänud koodi. Kirjutan lihtsalt iga kord lihtsalt niimoodi. Oot, oot, oot.
Õpetaja: Ja selle muudame Oota Mul sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsus ei ole vä?
Õpetaja: Ei saa teha kõik. Oi, oi, mis siin toimub? Siin mingid taustad, hakkab pihta. Teen Kõik asjad Teeme suurte tähtedega. Senikaua, kuni jääb meelde jõle kole, on seda vaadata. Nii
Õpetaja: meetodid ja ma välisest elust tööd. Aga mütsi? Keegi tuleb isegi välja. Keegi tarb isegi teda praegu
Õpetaja: aga tehniliselt võttes on võimalik teda käivitada on võimalik kaasa anda. Mingi suvaline väärtus, mis lihtsalt kukub selle sildi taha. Siin on juba päris kood,
Õpetaja: mis käivitatakse samamoodi. Näed, see asi
Õpetaja: siin on tegelikult sisend. Mis kasu sellest aktsiase meetodist oleks? Vaata, kui sa ei saa anda Urli ette, et ongi lihtsalt selles raamistikus, et kõik sõnumid lähevad ühe sama urli vihte.
Õpetaja: No et ta teeb midagi. Vaata, meil peab olema See meetod on ka näe See meetod, kus iganes Ee, keerulisel viisil on kirjutatud,
Õpetaja: on sisend url.
Õpetaja: Kui see siit ära võtta. Ma ei saa seda ära kustutada, ütleb, et seda ei ole võimalik ära kustutada Vaata, on ju? Kui ma kustutaksin selle Ära vaata, siis ongi, niimoodi. Et see kood selles koodis Ei ole võimalik mingit infot kaasa anda,
Õpetaja: kui see siin on olemas. Url String. No see on siin tüübikindlalt tehtud. Näete seda ts I Typescript,
Õpetaja: et, ee, siin ei ole tüübikindel, et samamoodi. Me peame ise looma selle võimekuse, Kui me. Vaadake neid teisi Service Get Cities request, Miks siin. Ei ole mingit sisendit?
Õpetaja: Miks siin ei ole, palun?
Õpetaja: No jah, ma küsin, miks parameetrit ei ole. See oli pigem mu küsimus,
Õpetaja: Sest siin pole vaja. Siin on see, et too kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole mingit kitsendavat infot. Meil pole sellele tegevusele. Too kõik linnad, Ütle, too kõik linnad. Aga mõtle nüüd ainult tallinnat. Vaata, et pole nagu Point I on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, saaks olla sisend. Näiteks County maakond.
Õpetaja: Too mulle kõik linnad ja siis seal on harjumaa. Too mulle harjumaa. Noh, pigem County Id.
Õpetaja: Mitte isegi, aga nagu idee järgi, on ju Mul ei ole mingit siin. Ei ole vaja, sest et mul ei ole mingit infot vaja selle tegevuseks. Aga teises oli ju vaja, vaata, et nõuab City Id väärtust
Õpetaja: kuskilt. Ta peab tulema. No ta tulebki kuskilt. Aga lihtsalt. Selle koodi ja selle konkreetse meetodi lõikest, ta tuleb väljastpoolt.
Õpetaja: Aga kui seda sildikest seal ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole võimalik. Siis Sa lihtsalt istudki eluaeg. Lihtsalt istud siin kui selle võtad ära Vaata, Ja missioon on see, et anna siia Ct Id väärtust. Siis sa nagu istud siin selle vilkuva noole juures ja mõtled, nagu, kus ma nüüd selle väärtuse saan,
Õpetaja: siis ma panen sisse null. Oota, aga siis ta ei too Tallinna omasid. Kui ma valin pärnu, ta ei Too pärnu omased. Ta ei too.
Õpetaja: Siis ongi see, et. Oot, oot, see peab kuskilt väljastpoolt tulema.
Õpetaja: No siis on vaja teha selline võimekus, Ennem teed selle. Ütleme, et see on siin. Esialgu nulli saad, ah? Näed,
Õpetaja: edaspidi saab käivitada ja see väärtus tuleb siia. Kui nüüd vaatame seda piiblit ka Seda väärtust saab siin muuta.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta praegu tagastab kõike. Vaata stoplite nagu. Tal kama. Vaata, ta vastab samamoodi Kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on see, et
Õpetaja: kui on null, toob kõik linnad. Kui on kaks, toob Tallinna, kui on kolm, toob tartu, kui oli üks, Siis tuleb viga. Vaata, et pärnul ei ole midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd läheme tagasi sinna.
Õpetaja: Otsime nüüd ülesse. Kui me pooleli jäime, rohkem ei olegi. Me lisasime selle võimekuse ära, et seda on nüüd võimalik kasutada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil vaja samamoodi teha. Siis päriselt siia. Methods bloki, üks Meetod, mis toob ära Location Id.
Õpetaja: See Alert või City Id sajab siia allapoole.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla
Õpetaja: okei seda korra, et ma panen niiöelda Suureks Üldse on? Parem teha. Ma panen siin Claire ja Cancell.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja kuskile andmed panna vastutajale ju,
Õpetaja: mis võiks panna. Ee, siis Selle Muutuja nimeks, kus elavad, elab sees list.
Õpetaja: Sellistest objektidest, arvestades, et meil on siin Urlil Locations Locations City Id list. Ei,
Õpetaja: ma mõtlen, et kuidas võtta kogu see objekt kokku? Vaata, mis muutuja nime taha sa panna.
Õpetaja: City ideelist vist ei tööta eriti hästi.
Õpetaja: Anestassia tahab pakkuda Täpselt, Locations võiks olla Gate Locations. Nii
Õpetaja: kui me juba mõtleme praegu välja, vaata, et kogu see info me hakkame nagu siin ennem oli Citys ja nüüd on Locations. Kui meil on nüüd vaja teha meetodeid, mis on siis võimalik käivitada
Õpetaja: näiteks Before lehekülje laadimisel. Mis võiks olla Selle meetodi nimi. Kui selle objekti nimi saab olema. Locations.
Õpetaja: Jah, kui ma. Kui ma näen, et siin, üleval on Object Location, siin on Meetod Get Locations. Ilmselt nad on omavahel seotud, eksole,
Õpetaja: Locations?
Õpetaja: Noh, see järjekord on nii kui töötada strikli niimoodi, vaata, et kuna meil tuleb Esimene, Kui Kui niimoodi teha tööd, nagu programmeerida, siis mina tavaliselt tööd teen. On see, et ma proovin täpselt nii kaua kaugele, kuni tuleb mingi tõrge, et ma pean vahepeal midagi muud tegema. Mingi nagu mingi teise muu osa ääres ma. Teen selle muu osa ära tulen. Tagasi Järjekord on pole erinev. Ma võin kohe teha selle databloki sinna. Selle
Õpetaja: Ee, mudeli valmis On ju, et mida ta hakkab andma, Ma võin seda pärast teha.
Õpetaja: Minule meeldib niimoodi, et mul on Flow mõttes kogu aeg, mis on mul praegu takistav tegur, mille ma pean ära progema Liikuda edasi.
Õpetaja: Vaata, sa lähed samm sammult. Kui sa hakkad tegema nagu asju, ette, ära vaata, siis on alati see risk, et sa teed Mingeid asju, mis pärast? Tuleb välja, et ei olegi vaja. Siis hakka kustutama. Kustutamisel võiks vigu tulla. Kustutad mingeid sümboleid ära ja nii edasi On ju,
Õpetaja: et ma olen alati selle Flowga, et ma lähen täpselt nii kaugele, kui ma saan. Ja kui tuleb mingisugune stop peale, et Mul on ma nagu sõltun millestki. Mul on mingi muu asi vaja korra ära teha, Siis ma lähen teen selle asja ära ja naasen Tagasi Sinna, kus Ma Pooleli jäin.
Õpetaja: Selle vlogga me praegu täpselt olen. Seda teinud, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi see, et ee, nüüd on ideergi üldse võimalik seda käivitada. Vaata, näitab, et keegi seda käivitab, Aga tegelikult ta ajab mingit jama meile. Praegu pole siin seda kuskil käivitatud, kus Me tahame seda käivitada
Õpetaja: taas. Muidugi ütleb seda iseenesest. Siin. Ka Ee räägib meile sellest.
Õpetaja: Aa, lustage niimoodi
Õpetaja: nüüd ja see ütleb, see peab olema. Lehele oma
Õpetaja: lehele maandudes. Ja veel öeldakse, et esialgu tuuakse ta ära nulliga. Okei,
Õpetaja: ee, no väga Tore Lehele maandudes siis mida me käivitama peame.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, jah,
Õpetaja: jah, okei, jah.
Õpetaja: Formaat on meil olemas.
Õpetaja: Käivitame seda meetodit, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kirjutame siia Get Locations Suud ka
Õpetaja: Nüüd see Meetod käivitub. Ma võin siin mingi alerdi teha. Alert Ee,
Õpetaja: mida iganes. Tulen korra lehele ja näitan, et Ee, Jah, ta käivitatakse Locations küll Taipo Ga.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on siis see point, et nagu sai nagu vaeva nähtud, Siin sai käivitatud. Selline
Õpetaja: tähendab sai ehitatud selline meetod, mis Päriselt saadab sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma seda saan välja kutsuda?
Õpetaja: Elles Miks Els?
Õpetaja: Ja siis me Ls. Iga tahame kiirelt saada Location Service Me viitame Mingi teisele failile. Kus sees on mingi meetod? Kuidas meetodeid saab käivitada?
Õpetaja: No punktiga on ju
Õpetaja: See idea näitab meile ära, näiteks, noh, kogu Selle asja saab niimoodi kirjutada, et ma seda asja ei vaata. Otseselt, onju? Ma tean, et seal on. Kirjutan service punkt. Nüüd ma näen, Mis meetodid siin on? Näitab, et mis ta sisse võtab. Vihje on siin. Ka
Õpetaja: City Id.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on selline meetod, mida ta tagastab, Ta ütleb. Aa, okei, Ta ütleb, tagastab. Void
Õpetaja: ei annagi midagi. Meile Mingi väikene pugi on juba sees,
Õpetaja: et meil on ju vaja siis, et Tulev objekt ja objekti pealt käivitub Meetod või Catch või final mis iganes,
Õpetaja: aga ta ütleb, et ta, ei tagastagi midagi.
Õpetaja: No mis Kurat, no lähme vaatame.
Õpetaja: Klikime selle sama kontrolliga. Selle Location Service peale tuleb see fail lahti. Mis probleem siin on?
Õpetaja: Jah, et praegult on Niimoodi, et see asi näitab. Et Kuule, Mina returnin sulle promiss Objekti, ma luban. Näete, siin all näitab. Ka. Vaata, ma ei saa vist liigutada, siis ta läheb ära. Tema tagastab promiss, objekti ja ta ütleb, et promiss. Return from gett is ignored. Mitte midagi sa ei tee, Sellega
Õpetaja: ei lähe kuhugi Muutujasse. Põhiline asi on see, et see asi elab ja sureb.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, objektid elavad ja surevad täpselt nende loogiliste sulgude vahel. Kus see Staff toimub?
Õpetaja: Kogu selle vahel nagu midagi. Toimub. Kõik mis siin on, See läheb musta auku ära. Kus asi saab läbi?
Õpetaja: Me tahaksime seda, nagu. Kui panna niimoodi pikalt pannakse selle, et ee, Introduce Local varjable.
Õpetaja: Näe, püüan kinni. Nüüd on vähemalt kinni püütud See hall tekst on? Seda ärge kaasa tehke, Aga nüüd on vist niimoodi, et näed seda muutujat, mis siin on. See on hall, onju? Keegi Seda ei kasuta.
Õpetaja: See objekt, mis on seotud selle mutoga, elab ja sureb siin. Kui ma returniksin selle. Vähemalt ma läksin liiga kaugele. Kui ma selle objekti siis tehniliselt kõik töötaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta lihtsalt ütleb, et. Kuule, sa lood uue sildikese. No juba järgmisel real, sest et see on järgmine nagu rida. Nagu skoobi mõttes.
Õpetaja: Juba järgmisel real. Sa tagastad selle. Ta ütleb, et. Kuule, pane lihtsalt see sama koodirida sellele samale Reale, mis? Ee muutuja on? Varjable, vaata.
Õpetaja: Noh, lõpptulemus ongi, et return tuleb ette.
Õpetaja: Siin on lihtsalt see, et see meetod kett tagastab objekti,
Õpetaja: Aga ta muidu sureb ära. Lihtsalt meil siin.
Õpetaja: Meil on nagu see, et. Kuule, returni.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd tuleme siia, vaatame siis tagasi ja Ma vaatan uuesti, panen siin. Punkt
Õpetaja: näitab, et ta võtab sisendi. Ee, niiöelda sellest tabelist ta kahjuks ei oska näidata paremal pool, mida ta tagastab, et see on promitisobjekt, Aga vahet pole, Näitab Voidi,
Õpetaja: et ma unusta ära ka, et see tööriist on mõeldud tegelikult Aa Backendi arendamiseks,
Õpetaja: et ta ei ole. Ma kujutan ette mingi Web Storm is. Kuskil on see rohkem ära progetud,
Õpetaja: et ta saab aru, nagu mida see asi tagastab.
Õpetaja: Noh, läksin siia peale. Juba ütleb, et nõuab City Id.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, noh, nüüd me olemegi siis siin, et nagu ise võiks anda siit ette. Praegult näiteks kahe
Õpetaja: või nulli.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on see mõte. Vaata, et kord peab ta olema null. Kord peab olema. Ta Üks Kord peab olema ta kaks. Mida iganes See, mis sealt ee valitakse,
Õpetaja: Mis Mõtteid teil praegu siin? Selle City Id Ga on? Me ei saa teha niimoodi, et me kirjutamegi siia sisse mingi numbrilise väärtuse. Kuna see peab olema ajas muutuv. No siin on juba vihje
Õpetaja: ajas Muutub see info, mis meil on vaja?
Õpetaja: Mhm, dünaamilised muutujat. Kuidas ma siin seda peaks tegema?
Õpetaja: Ei, Call on City Id, millele see viitaks Kool on City Id siin. Pole
Õpetaja: Aga kui me räägime, et uut muutuja, No kus me siin teeme? Uusi muutujaid?
Õpetaja: Muidugi, Databloki, et Düna, Sest et see meetod ei tea ma välisest elus töödega mütsi. Küll on tal ligipääs nendele asjadele, on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, teeme uue muutuja, kuna Ta on Niukene üherealine. Siis ma pigem teeks selle. Siia.
Õpetaja: No mis võiks olla siis selle muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: City. No millest jutt Käib, Noh, City Id St.
Õpetaja: City Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus, mis võiks olla tema väike väärtus. See on tegelikult taaskis Lausa ette öeldud
Õpetaja: lehele laad. Lao Laadides peaks olema. See null on okei. Sobib
Õpetaja: City Id null. Kui mina. Nüüd tulen tagasi siia meetodisse.
Õpetaja: Kus me. Kus see nüüd on, siin all on ootab sisse Sisendit City Id.
Õpetaja: No kuidas ma saan nüüd anda, et saad väärtuse?
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan ise ja viitan data Blokile
Õpetaja: City Id esimesel katsel. Kui lehte laetakse, on tema väärtus
Õpetaja: null. Isegi et ma olen seda nagu praegult siin toimetanud. Kuidas saaks juba testida, et kas idee järgi siis töötab see asi või mitte
Õpetaja: Browserist, kui tulla siia. No teen refresh I ka. Refresh Iden. Peale, seda teen lahti inspekti. Kuidas ma saaksin praegu? Mille mingi datablokiga? Ta ei ole üldse muutu. Seotud on ju? Kuidas ma saan vaadata, kas Backendile sõnum läheb või ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Mis tööriist meid aitab. Siin Network. Muidugi,
Õpetaja: Network. No mina korra muutsin ära selle, et ta ei filtreeri aga las Ta filtreerib sõnumid, mis lähevad läbi,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen nüüd. Refresh
Õpetaja: läks sõnum teele Get Cities. Me saime varasemalt ära. Programmeeritud. No see on Ju see siin eksole
Õpetaja: läks? Vaatame. Seda Get Locations läks niimoodi, et City Id väärtus läheb. Quer. I Parameetrina null Seal peale klikid. On Enamvähem kogu sõnumit
Õpetaja: läks Niuke sõnum, Mis me vastuseks saime,
Õpetaja: Siin on see vastus. Stoplight vastas.
Õpetaja: Noh, seal on niimoodi, et see sõnum läheb Frontendile. Frontend saadab edasi proxy seadistusega. Ee, selle Stop light ile pärast läheb Backendile, onju? Me suhtleme läbi Frontend I browser. Tegelikult see on Nagu veits. Veider mõelda niimoodi. Vaata, Browser saadab sõnumi kõigepealt, et anna mulle Html
Õpetaja: Ee Frondile. Front annab selle ära. Nüüd ta saab uuesti, nagu. Anna mulle nüüd. Ta saab Frontile. Vaata, anna mulle nüüd see info appi. Ka. Kriips Locations Nii, edasi.
Õpetaja: Content pikib selle üles ja Vaatab. Et see algab sõnaga appi. Järelikult see on mõeldud hoopis kellelegi teisele. Lükkame selle sõnumi edasi Backendile, mis see nagu lahendab ära, et on see, et,
Õpetaja: ee, et, ee. Sa ei pea nagu, ee, koodi seda ära defineerima sisse. Vaata, nagu sa. Nagu, et sa ei pea Saatma seda otse Back end Ile. See on ka variant.
Õpetaja: See on arhitektuuriline. Otsus saab ka teha niimoodi, et me ei mängi läbi frontend I, vaata. Serveri saab otse ka panna. Siis tuleb lihtsalt veits teistmoodi kontida. Aga nimed on palju lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Teil on Mul on tegelikult ainult Massiivi osa.
Õpetaja: Sa räägid seda siin vä? Aga nüüd ongi erinevad objektid.
Õpetaja: Kas on?
Õpetaja: Vot sa pead. Natuke Räägi ridade kaupa minu ekraanil, mis Sa teed
Õpetaja: taotab kokku näha totavlogidena.
Õpetaja: Iga kolmteist on üldse on. Ja
Õpetaja: jah, nüüd kui sa all pöördud, siis Riga kolmkümmend kuus,
Õpetaja: siis millise City Poole et olla veendunud, et tegelikult on.
Õpetaja: No aga väga lihtne. Tõmba need mitmekihilised asjad kokku. Vaata, on ju? No mis sa arvad, Mille poole ta pöörab?
Õpetaja: Kas me oleme juba tegelikult teinud? Tuletame loo kinni. Korra meelde. Läheme korra
Õpetaja: siin. Kus meil on datablokis? Teeme veidi asju lahti.
Õpetaja: Mitte Login Service, vaid Tahad sa minna? Log in View?
Õpetaja: Kas teil tuleb meelde, et meil on niiöelda inputid? Need kastikesed on seotud Log in request punkt Username,
Õpetaja: et see on, see et ühe niiöelda objekti sees on teised andmed Login Request. Username.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu Samasugune asi. Vaata selle asja.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Kas sa mõtled seda, et kui klikida selle peale siin või
Õpetaja: jah, okei, no see on idea, Vaata, ma mõtlen, ma ei tea, kas ta kuidagi kui niimoodi vaata värvib midagi. Ei värvi. Jah, okei, nüüd ma saan aru, mis sa Mõtled
Õpetaja: jah, aga ei. Ta mõtleb ikka seda. Vaata ja. Ja
Õpetaja: ta mõtleb sada seda. Vot siin ongi, see et vaata, kuidas ta nagu Siis kuidagi taustal toimetab, ongi see, et tal on kuidagi ära programmeeritud. Niiöelda, et kui sa klikid mingi sõnale, siis ta lihtsalt findiga kõina otsib neid. Vaata, on ju ta. Ma ütlen ka, et see see tööriist ei ole mõeldud. Primer I Vaata, et teha üldse näiteks frontend Arendus
Õpetaja: Ee voeraamistikus. Ka See on hästi spetsiifiline. Siin on mingid bluginad ja asjad, vahel mis seal enamvähem nagu tal talutavaks teeb. Selle. Siin. Ee, aga eelkõige ta on ikkagi mõeldud jaava või skaala programmeerimiseks.
Õpetaja: Seal ta töötab paremini kui on sarnaseid olukordasid, kus on samanimelised muutuvad, Mitu korda, siis ta saab aru Ikkagi, et kuidas. Tegelikult asjad on omavahel seotud.
Õpetaja: Siin Ta kahjuks ei saa. Kui me jõuame Backendi, siis ma Korra proovin. Kui meil on mingi objekt ja mingi muuta, et kuidas ta seal peast juba tean, et ta minu meelest Highlight Ib sealt Neid korrektselt on mingi analooges situatsiooni oskan teha.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: me juba nägime, et sõnum läheb teele ja vastused saadakse. Noh, väga hea, nüüd ongi Siis vaja hakata programmeerima seda, et, ee, et kui see sõnum saadetakse, et mis me siis selle vastusega teeme?
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia taha nüüd Kirjutan,
Õpetaja: kui see kogu asi annab mulle objekti. Aa, kust võib tulla? Vastus või mitte. Vaata, võib ka tulla. Mingi timeout, on Ju Mina Tahan nüüd siis toimetada erinevate olukordadega,
Õpetaja: kui on nagu mingi hea vastus. Aga on halb vastus. Jah, Mhmh Teeme. Ten bloki
Õpetaja: seda kutsuks keti Niiöelda tegemine, onju?
Õpetaja: Muudkui läheb punktide abil edasi painali
Õpetaja: ja visuaalselt lüüa need üksteise alla.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Korra Läheme eelmise ee teenuse juurde Tagasi Siin on korra Catš mure.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, Ee, siin Selles task is ei mainita seda.
Õpetaja: Ma tean see selleks Praegu Ma korra tulen praegu tagasi selle Cities. See, mis teeb
Õpetaja: seal teenuses ei ole öeldud, et tuleb ühtegi viga.
Õpetaja: Ee, get Cities. Siin ei ole öeldud, et ta tegelikult, ee, Ta vaikimisi näitab. Viiesaja vist siia ma ei tea, kas näitab või ei näita,
Õpetaja: et siin ei ole ühtegi viga, mis on niiöelda programmeeritud Viga aga on see, et kui midagi läheb serveris, täiesti tuksi. Null Point, er Error server kukub maha. Andmebaas kukub maha Vahet. Pole, see on serveri sisemine viga. Vaata, see tuleb viiesajana,
Õpetaja: et ee. Meil taaskis Ei oldud nagu siin ära öeldud, et mis saab siis kui aga See on Niukene asi. Vaata, et. Noh, see on niikuinii. Tuleb arvestada, et iga vastuse puhul saab tulla alati internal server error ja siis On vaja kasutajale ka midagi mõelda. Nüüd on vaja mõelda, Mis see kriitilisus on? Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui meie kogu info kuvatakse põhimõtteliselt rippmenüü pealt,
Õpetaja: siis on küsimus seda. Vaata, Kui rippmenüü sisu ei saa,
Õpetaja: siis kas on üldse mõtet meil kasutajal seda lehte näidata kuidagi pooliklikult, või Me ütleme talle, et
Õpetaja: Ups midagi ei läheks valesti, sest vahel on olukorrad, kus on täiesti okei. Vaata, et sa võibolla kuuad mingit väikest Alerti kuskile vaata,
Õpetaja: ei saanud laadida mingeid ee, linnaandmeid või midagi taolist, Aga mingit muud infot saaks, onju? Sa nagu selles mõttes nagu arhitektuuriline Otsus, et mida me siis teeme, kui andmeid ei tule?
Õpetaja: Kuidas tudengluuserid närivad?
Õpetaja: No jah, no me saame mingit selles mõttes, et me me saaksime siin vähemalt me teame, mis osaga see on seotud. See on seotud ee. Andmetega on ju, et me saame siin tegelikult täiesti vabalt Kasutajale ka kuvada, et
Õpetaja: midagi asemele saab seda öelda, et kahjuks ee, mingi süsteemi viga ei saanud laadida linnade rippenüümeid,
Õpetaja: aga ta näeb seda tabelit. Äkki tabeliandmed õnnestub ära tuua. Kasvõi kõik linnad abil on ju Filtreerimist ei saa nüüd teha. Kahjuks vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et see on nagu otsustus küsimus. Aga Pigem on nagu siis niimoodi. Vaata, et kõik või mitte midagi. Noh, see meenutab. Meie armsat Gretet, vaata temaga on See, et vahel nagu reklaamime talle midagi alguses välja, et. Oota, Davai, Lähme teeme midagi. No viieteist. Aastane teismeline. Kogu aeg on see nii öelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, et midagi saab välja reklaamitud. Mingi esialgne idee saab nagu välja reklaamitud, et teeme midagi ja siis on niimoodi, et kui mingi Hetk tuleb mingisugune modifikatsioon sinna plaani. Vaata, et et soovime midagi teistmoodi teha. Siis tal on niimoodi Ei, siis ei soovi. Ei,
Õpetaja: ta on ju kõik või mitte midagi. Ee, meil on ka mõned kohad, kus me tegelikult ee. Programmis otsustame, kas kõik või mitte midagi, et kas Sa näitad sa selle korrektselt. Või siis ütled, et. Noh, ei saa praegu.
Õpetaja: Noh, minu vaates on see pigem nagu, ee, libe tee hakata Nagu midagi osaliselt kuvama ja mihk. Sest et seal on nii palju variatsiooni, siis, kuidas mida saab teha, vajutada, et
Õpetaja: mis on nähtav olnud, Minu meelest on nagu lihtsam seda. Vaata. No kui midagi läheks ka, ütleme. Mul on asjad programmeeritud korrektselt ja midagi läheks tuksi selle rippmenüüga, Siis vist ei ole eriti suurt tõenäosust, et seal lähevad asjad ka hästi
Õpetaja: ühe järgmise sõnumiga, et see on Kandaat Ups, midagi läheks valesti olukord.
Õpetaja: No siis ongi see, et see Catchblock siin sellel eelmisel teenusel vajab natukene täiendamist.
Õpetaja: Siis Mina pakun, et siia Control tühik Aa, teha see Landa lambda niiöelda funktsioon siia ette.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me ei hakka tegelikult seal peal midagi kontrollima. Et mis viga see oli ja mis sisu? Ee, sellepärast, et meil ei ole ühtegi programmeeritud viga. Sealt saabki tulla ainult viissada praegu, et vähemalt
Õpetaja: sageli sõnade kohaselt midagi muud ei saa tulla,
Õpetaja: kui ainult see, et ee, vea mõttes saab tulla Internal server error, et see tähendab seda, et mul ei ole siin tegelikult seekord Praegult, kui me sisse logides me tahtsime vaadata, et kas on status nelisada kolm ja siis error kood on No mis iganes see oli, Vaata vale kasutajanimi parool. Seal oli meil midagi sisulist vaadata.
Õpetaja: Meil oli vaja muutujat.
Õpetaja: Kus sees informatsioon siis nagu elab
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nagu niimoodi, et tegelikult meil on vaja lihtsalt käivitada tegevust. Siis me saame teha niimoodi, et me uut sildikest siia ei loo,
Õpetaja: aga peale seda noolt saame midagi käivitada.
Õpetaja: No mida me tahame siis teha? Me tahame kasutaja suunata. Ups, midagi läheks vaatelehele, On nii?
Õpetaja: Error. Page. Jah, me tahame Kasutaja sinna niiöelda suunata.
Õpetaja: Keegi mäletab, kuidas seda sai teha. Aga miks Router Push. Me tegime asi koodi palju mõnusamalt loetavamaks.
Õpetaja: Navigation Service ajal Tegime eraldi. Meetodid oli nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis Ns.
Õpetaja: Navigation Service.
Õpetaja: Sa ei pea midagi Oletama ja aru punkt, vaata Onju Okei, aga see nüüd Põhimõtteliselt näitab meetodit, mis on seal olemas. Mis see meile sobib?
Õpetaja: Jaa, nad ei olnud error Page.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui lihtne see oli, sest et Siin ei olnud midagi kontrollida.
Õpetaja: Location Services. Vaatame, mis ta siin selle kohta jääpib. Mis võimalikud vead on? Korra vaatame. Ee, täiesti pangatasuke. See On see sama ikka, onju? Kakssada on ära öeldud.
Õpetaja: Siis on öeldud nelisada. Not found ja viissada ei ole siin ära mainitud aga tegelikult, Viissada on igal juhul, et olla ka et alati tahab sellele mõelda.
Õpetaja: Kui me hakkame pärast seda asja progema, siis seal Catch bloki tuleb Natuke rohkemat.
Õpetaja: Meid muidugi huvitab. Nüüd see Gat Locations ja Den Block üldse.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on jälle see samamoodi, et meil on, ee, vaja siin siis mõttes teha lambda funktsioon. See on siis selline funktsioon, kus
Õpetaja: vasakul poolt noolekest on mingi muutuja nimi.
Õpetaja: Kontrol tühikuga. Saame mingi niukse asja Meile see ei meeldi. Meile meeldib response.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see, et mis siis nüüd tegema hakkab, Onju paremalt poolt. Nool on action, mis Nüüd kood, nagu edasi peab käivitama ja tegema.
Õpetaja: Noh, me nüüd tahame jätkata seda sama mustrit, et mingit pikka koodi me siia ei hakka kirjutama, vaid viime selle tegevuse ära abimeetodisse. Kui ma mõtlen, ütlen, et see on abimeetod, siis teil peaks see kohvimasin kohe silme ette lööma
Õpetaja: Ket Cappuccino on nagu meet põhiline meetod, mida käivitame.
Õpetaja: Meetodid, mida välja kutsutakse, on abimeetodid.
Õpetaja: Meil on samamoodi praegu siin. Olukord, et
Õpetaja: me tahame Nüüd Get Locations on siis see niiöelda põhiline meetod, mis käivitatakse sellel meetodil. See meetod käivitab abimeetodit. Midagi mis aitab teda,
Õpetaja: et ee,
Õpetaja: jah, siin. Hästi, mängib kokku praegult selle meetodi nimega Handle Get Locations Response.
Õpetaja: No üleval. Tegime samamoodi. Vaata, Get Cities Response onju?
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on jällegi. Ee, et teha, üldse, et see, et süsteem saaks aru, et see on meetod, mitte mingisugune muutuja. Näiteks paned need sulud
Õpetaja: ja nüüd Ongi see sulgude sisu jälle. Vaata, et kas anda midagi kaasa või mitte. Ma korra teen sellest meetodi ära.
Õpetaja: Mis on sellise meetodiga Paha Lugu on see, et see meetod
Õpetaja: ei tea oma välisest elus tööd ega mütsi ja midagi kaasa ka ei tule,
Õpetaja: kui ma siin tahaksin, et. Okei, ma nüüd tahan toimetada nende respons andmetega. Siis mul oleks nagu.
Õpetaja: Okei. Aga mille poole ma nüüd? Nagu siis, Millele ma nüüd viidata saan. Minu mängumaa on nii lühikene.
Õpetaja: Midagi siin ka ei ole. Eespool ka ühes kirjas. Ütleme, et mul on kuus rida koodi. Vaata, Kus iganes sa hetkel oled, Sinu mängumaa on kõik, mis on siiamaani olemas.
Õpetaja: Kuni siia piirini, on ju kaasa arvatud siis suu sugudes sisu,
Õpetaja: Et niukest meetodit mitte teha. Siis Ongi see, et muidu see asi. Ta ütleb, et keegi mind Ei, kasuta.
Õpetaja: See info läheb sul lihtsalt kaotsi
Õpetaja: Kui see sildikene saab oma info ja kood jookseb vasakult paremale lõpuni, kaasa arvatud see meetod käivitub Mida iganes, siis see kood saab otsa ja siin sureb siin. Selles. Kohas sureb respons lihtsalt ära.
Õpetaja: Siis me peame ütlema, et Kuule, kanna kaasa.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et Respons Handlyd mingit Response. Aga Response? Ennast seal abi meetodes polegi.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on nüüd see õige koht, kus siis ee, luua see meetod ja tema loeb selle põhja ise ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta mõtleb, et äkki see hakkab midagi retörnima ja ei hakka ta midagi retörnima.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me oleme siis nagu seal maal et meil tegelikult see respons on olemas. Ja responsi sees on siis ee. Selline sisu
Õpetaja: nüüd on meil vaja kuskil seda sisu Hoida
Õpetaja: Data datablokk. Data bloki. Me juba teame, et me peame mõtlema mingi muutuja nime välja. Kui see nimi on, kui siin oli selle asja nimi Get Location. Siis me teame, et see võiks olla
Õpetaja: Ei, minul mitte.
Õpetaja: Võibolla Jaroslavil on juba.
Õpetaja: No data pole aga peamine asi on siis see, mis tuleb nüüd siis piiblist haarata? On see mudel
Õpetaja: siis, kui te Back End Id selle käivitate, seal on ta niimoodi Anonüümne
Õpetaja: on null ja siin on lihtsalt sõna. String String. Siin on mingi null. Null,
Õpetaja: null, string. Noh, ma ei mäleta, kumb ta vaikimisi on Ainult üks objekt massiivi Sees. Siin on nagu natuke teistmoodi. Stoplight is on ta kirjeldav niiöelda. Jason, siin on natukene rohkem,
Õpetaja: aga poleks Kogu see asi koos sulgede ja karvadega võtta,
Õpetaja: tekitab see kuidagi raskust. Ma ei tea, kas seal kopinupu ei ole või mis te ette
Õpetaja: võib ka võtta Tegelikult niimoodi. Noh, see siis vajab täpsust. Vaata, et võt selle kandilise sulu võib ise ka panna. Lihtsam on võtta kogu See tekst neid sealt. Aga mitte niimoodi, et. Noh, et siit üle
Õpetaja: vaid ikka lõpeb siin ära.
Õpetaja: Control C, Nüüd Temast saab ka olema Mitmekihiline niiöelda objekt, nagu see City ski. Teeme siia alla natukene ruumi.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt paneme nime ja kooloni
Õpetaja: locations. Me paneme selle plöraki maha.
Õpetaja: Näed Seekord tegi ta. Minul tegi ka ilusti Javascripti objektiks. Kuidas ma saan aru et see on jaavas kripto objekt mitte Jason.
Õpetaja: Võtmetel pole jutumärke onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nagu see, et siin siin on Tegelikult mitu objekti? Siin on? Mitu objekti sees. Kas teil tegi ka ära niimoodi või Jäid jutumärgid. Seekord ei teinud. Siis te saate Ida kogu selle teksti
Õpetaja: ja kollase pirniga peaks olema. Niukene valik nagu Unquote. Mina ei saa Unquote ide. Ma saan vastupidi teha.
Õpetaja: Ma saan panna just koodid.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja siis ma saaks põhimõtteliselt võtta selle. Võin ka niimoodi võtta. Võtta Võtate kokku?
Õpetaja: Teen Ee. Ma ei tea, kas ta niimoodi. Kui ta ei näita. Samal ajal saan öelda, et unquote
Õpetaja: nii, aga nüüd on Põhiline asi, et siin on tegelikult kolm objekti selles näidises Meil on vaja mudelis ainult ühte objekti. Ma paneks lihtsalt nagu nende loogiliste sulgude juurest Niimoodi need
Õpetaja: kinni on? Kolm objekti.
Õpetaja: Tsikupilli prisma Tondiselver, Jääprisma Mis sinu plaan on?
Õpetaja: Kaks? Saadame pensionile niimoodi. Lihtsalt valida need read ja lihtsalt vajutada Backspace I ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd teeks selle asja natukene. Ee, selles mõttes. Nii nagu ta standardina on. Siin on igasugused päris andmed, aga Need andmed niikuinii tulevad. Back endist siia. Võiks lihtsalt anda nagu väga neutraalsel viisil aru saada, et mis tüüpi andmed siin käivad. Location Id võiks olla null.
Õpetaja: String võiks olla tühi. String Tallinn. Kas teil on ka üksikkülaga omad vä?
Õpetaja: Siis need võib lihtsalt ära kustutada. Siis võib kogu teksti ära lihtsalt kustutada ja teha
Õpetaja: lihtsalt vajutada üksikülaga omasid Oota, kas siin läks valesti? See on number number,
Õpetaja: No Ma teen Samamoodi siis, nagu et, ee. Kustutan kõik ära või teen siniseks ja vajutan lihtsalt. Ei, ma ikkagi. Paitan üksikkülaga oma escape
Õpetaja: True Falls, las Nad olla truutses.
Õpetaja: Aa see nüüd Transaction typesiga on samamoodi. Meil on ainult mudelit vaja. Et mis siin Transaction Type ide sees käib, meil Ei ole vaja seda raha sisse. Raha, välja. Meil ei ole vaja kolme objekti. Kindluse mõttes võib siis tõmmata korra nad kokku. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Jällegi Meil on lihtsalt ühekordselt vaja aru saada,
Õpetaja: et mis siin nagu ideeliselt sees saaks käia.
Õpetaja: Vot see nüüd on, Ee, see nüüd on ee, Loetav mudel. Ma kogemata kommenteerisin sisse välja selle asja. See nüüd on. Ühekordselt. Enam enam kitsamalt ei ole võimalik edasi anda seda mudelit,
Õpetaja: kõike asja sinna ainult ühe. Korra.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, mis siin sees on. Id Location Name Cityname longitud laditud
Õpetaja: transaction types. Mis on massiiv Massiivi Sees Käivad niuksed, objektid. Kus on Transaction Type Transactionamed Is Available
Õpetaja: näidisandmeid Siis saab alati kõrvalt vaadata, et mis seal nagu on, et Location Id Location Name City Name laditud
Õpetaja: raha sisseraha välja. Maksed True True True Mõtted on nagu seal olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on. Meil see takistus on üle saadud nende vahepeal, kui mitte. Kas keegi tuleb järgi?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil nagu see eeldus tehtud, et Ee tehniliselt meil on võimalik nüüd ee seda Back endist. Ee, niiöelda tulevat vastust kuhu sisse panna.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil see sildike olemas.
Õpetaja: Locations on see sildika Jällegi nagu varasemalt arutasime, Nagu, ee, ei ole mõtet teha. Näiteks mingi location list.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt panna mitmusesse.
Õpetaja: See tähendabki, et neid on palju. Ilmselt ongi see mingi massiivne asi.
Õpetaja: No nii, Push. Läks tulla järgi.
Õpetaja: No, kes tahab? Võib juba korra proovida progeda seda kohta.
Õpetaja: Mis te sinna kirjutate?
Õpetaja: Facebooki?
Õpetaja: Jah, kuidas Sa ütlesid, Vaata, kõigepealt viitab siis sellele samale sildile. Locations
Õpetaja: ei saa lihtsalt Locations kirjutada, et saaks aru, et see on siin selles failis Locations.
Õpetaja: Tahan anda talle mingit sisu Võrdusmärk seda teeb.
Õpetaja: Noh, lähme siis. Kas nüüd võib edasi minna? Käsi püsti? Kes veel tahab, et ootaks?
Õpetaja: Ootan,
Õpetaja: teadsid?
Õpetaja: Ee, lähme siis sinna Handel Ee Locations siia.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis mõte on see, et tahaks nüüd viidata sellele samale objektile. No ma Proovin nii palju asju kinni panna, Kui saadad. Kas nad ühele ekraanile mahuvad?
Õpetaja: Mina tahan viidata sellele objektile.
Õpetaja: Panen talle näpu külge. Niimoodi ütlen This Punkt
Õpetaja: locations. See on see, et ma puudutan seda data bloki. Nagu ma korra vajutan. Ma ei tea, kas keegi on hiir, kellel on Back ja nupud ka küljes.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saate üli tšillid liitu liikuda? Näiteks, et klikid selle peale, et hüppab sinna, kus on Locations,
Õpetaja: Kui Vajutate Packi tuleb. Tagasi. Kus siis käisid? Back ja Forward? Oi, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mul hakkab hiir vaikselt läbi minema.
Õpetaja: Back töötab. Forward töötab kuidagi nigelalt
Õpetaja: Edasi, tagasi. Ee, vaadake, Muidugi, Keyboard. I Peal saab ka. Kuidas saab Keyboard It edasitagasi liikuda, kus ma olen juba kolistanud
Õpetaja: Control alt ja Siis nool vasakule.
Õpetaja: Mul paremale, et klikid kuhugi ära Tähendab, Mis klikid? Lähed? Näiteks seda Control Bga Niiöelda. Control Binocilor, Otsi
Õpetaja: Ee, Lähen siia. Adam Locations Isse,
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab tagasi minna Kontrolli alt. Ja nüüd leht. Mine tagasi vasakule.
Õpetaja: Mine edasi paremale.
Õpetaja: Saate niimoodi ka liikuda. Ee, niimoodi On eriti hea, kui hüppab erifeilide vahel ja nii edasi. Kiirelt läheb nii. Viitame sellele sildikesele. Ütleme, et saa sinna. Uus sisu.
Õpetaja: Respons on Kogu sisu sulgeda ja karvadega. Kogu See vastus üldse. Taotlused asjad. Ma Ei, tea, seal on tõesti. Mingi väga palju mingit informatsiooni küljes. Meid ainult huvitab
Õpetaja: data Sellise liigutusega. Me nüüd teeme niimoodi, et see Locations andmed lähevad sinna kuidas saab kohe kontrollida,
Õpetaja: kus töötab, sest me oleme Ja ära progetud, et
Õpetaja: käivitatakse. Ee, käivitatakse see siit Locations. Iga sisend läheb sealt muutujast, Mis on null?
Õpetaja: Osa on meil ära tehtud. Kuidas saab proovida, Kas kõik töötab korrektselt veebilehel? Browser is Kuidas
Õpetaja: no inspektiga saab? Aga siit võibolla kiiremalt kasutada Sedagi et teeme selle voe dev Tools I lahti läheme. Atms View peale. On meil siin. Locations
Õpetaja: juba on refresh. Iga ära toodud on siku. Pilliprisma on tondi. Selver
Õpetaja: on jõeprisma, kui vaadata ühe Näiteks sikupiiri. Prisma Transaction types. E.
Õpetaja: Kolm tükki on True Pru Prou,
Õpetaja: Vaatame. Tondiselverit. Siin on ka kolm objekti.
Õpetaja: Paha Sisse on truu.
Õpetaja: Aa välja on truu ja maksed on foos.
Õpetaja: No nii, kõik info on olemas.
Õpetaja: Okei, väga hea,
Õpetaja: mis siis? Edasi
Õpetaja: No Võibolla nüüd sai siin vaeva nähtud, et andmed ära toodud, Et siis võiks olla andmete kasutus.
Õpetaja: See Siin on praegu lihtsalt kirjutatud ja ainult Üks näide, onju?
Õpetaja: See ju ei tule dünaamiliselt. Nüüd oleks vaja progeda, et kõik need read, mis on ja teenused eraldi
Õpetaja: pidadena tuleksid siia Nähtavale
Õpetaja: Ilmselt templite osas peaks kuskil toimetama.
Õpetaja: Pakkuge teie mulle. Vaata, et ee, mis real. Hakkame toimetama,
Õpetaja: kui vaatate ridade numbreid minu ekraanilt
Õpetaja: mis mõtet. Teil on sada. Kolmsada, neli, sada, kolm, Kuidas,
Õpetaja: kuidas? Üheksakümmend üheksa, Jah, üheksakümmend. Üheksa on vale Vastus ei sada.
Õpetaja: Sada on ka vale vastus. Me võime nüüd mängida seda mängu, et, ee, niiöelda kaks korda viis. Vaata, onju väiksel lapsel, vaata et hakkame siis pakkuma. Ei, kaks,
Õpetaja: Mida me teada saame? Mis see tööriist on? Või Võta, vaata, millega me tahame nüüd dünaamiliselt hakata seda Ee, sisu siia niiöelda genereerima
Õpetaja: head. Peavad olema dünaamilised. Mis element on Ee, siin selles tables.
Õpetaja: Rea oma R.
Õpetaja: Mm, Okei, sellepärast, et need peavad ju korduma nii mitu korda on andmeid vastatajale siis rida.
Õpetaja: Üheksakümmend kaheksa. Jah,
Õpetaja: vastab tõele. Kui mitte, siis saab ju kohe vaadata. Lihtne värk on see, et paned korra selle kinni vajutad. Control T.
Õpetaja: See On veel väga korra. Kontroll, tee. Kas tuleb ridu juurde?
Õpetaja: Noh, Seda, elementi peab tulema nüüd andmete pealt,
Õpetaja: Nii leidsime oma selle asja ülesse. Nüüd on siis see, et kuidas on võimalik nüüd dünaamiliselt mingi massiivi pealt seda rida, niiöelda dubleerida koos Erineva sisuga.
Õpetaja: Just veidi aega tagasi. Siin sai vist nagu tehtud midagi analoogset. Ja need ju tulid ka. Dünaamiliselt on nii
Õpetaja: V Four, väga hea. Tuleme selle sisse ja kasutame voe sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsust. V. Four.
Õpetaja: Ja mina õpetasin, et üks hästi väikene mall jätta meelde kuidagi küsimärkidega oli seotud.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk. In Küsimärk. On See süntaks. Hind paremal. Pool peab olema kollektsioon. Vasakul peab olema Mingi muutuja. Nimi tuleb meelde
Õpetaja: paremal pool. Nüüd me peame viitama mingisugusele Ee kollektsioonile, kus on palju elemente Locations.
Õpetaja: Kirjutad Locations nüüd? Väike trikk Siin City S. Ega see Nii hästi ei klappinud onju? Vasakule peale poole. On nüüd vaja lihtsalt ühte muutuja nime, mis igal tsüklil kasutatakse Iga objekti puhul niiöelda siis pidepunktina,
Õpetaja: mis Tuleks sinna vasakule poole muutuja nimeks, kuhu iga tsüklit topitakse. Üks objekt
Õpetaja: No muidugi, kui see asi on mitmuses, siis pange see ainult ainsasse. Vaadake, siin on trikk niikuinii. Te just kirjutasite. See Caret juba seisab veel siin.
Õpetaja: Näete ühe nõksa vasakule. Vajate shift i peal, copy.
Õpetaja: Lähed Edasi vasakule, et selle siniseks sa paned. Control V. Noh, tuli ainsuses
Õpetaja: mõned ingliskeelsed sõnad. Muidugi ei saa. Vaata, et Ctys ei saa, vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil see olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võime juba kohe vaadata. Vaata, mitu Table Road. Meil hetkel koodis on?
Õpetaja: Ainult üks, on ju Kui Me tuleme, vaatame juba Lahendust.
Õpetaja: On juba kolm.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et meie Backendi Jason Is on kolm location it.
Õpetaja: Praegu lihtsalt ta korrutab seda sama elementi. Kõik, mis siin on kolm. Korda
Õpetaja: igas, ühes on tallinn sikupilli prisma raha. Sisseraha välja, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleks siis vaja seda, teha Nagu me ennem tegime, et ei, ei, ei, et ei ole lihtsalt sisse kirjutatud tekst,
Õpetaja: vaid igakord selle üksiku objekti muutuja nime abil me Ütleme, et võta sealt sellest objektist. Mingisugune konkreetne väli.
Õpetaja: Noh, alustame siis. Ee. Sellest linnaga, kus meil on linna nimi.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame neid välja nimesi, mis meil siin on?
Õpetaja: Jah, aga sa ütlesid es i sinna lõppu praegu. Vähemalt minu kuulmise järgi.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: et tuleme otsime ülesse, Aga see selles mõttes see mudel ongi ülihea, et neil on olemas. Tehniliselt see asi töötaks niimoodi ka
Õpetaja: ja sisu tuleb ju niikuinii mujalt, Siin on ka see värk. Vaata, et kuidas teil võivad asjad ee tuksi minna. Kui te Back Endist midagi muudate, teie programmeerite, et võtad sellest objektist välja. Nime Ka Citynay.
Õpetaja: Kui see on nüüd taustal tegelikult muutunud, et päriselt Jasonist. Tuleb midagi muud, siis see programm saab nulli null. Ta ei leia enam. Citynam I. Äkki see on. Ma ei tea või mis iganes on vahepeal muutunud,
Õpetaja: et see on see, kuidas Te praegu konkreetsel ajahetkel programmeerite. See eeldab seda, et tegelikult taustal on ka see mudel endiselt sama,
Õpetaja: kui päriselt muutub, aga mudel jääb siin samasse koodimuudatusi ei tee, siis tuleb põhiliselt
Õpetaja: kui näiteks mina ütleksin praegult. Kunagi oli näiteks seal mingi Location County. Näiteks Kanti Oih ground i Name.
Õpetaja: Näiteks kui minul on programmeeritud mingi siukene asi siia, et nüüd toimeta selle Location County Name iga.
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult seda seal Jasonis ei Ole siis see osa lihtsalt saab. Nal I, Vaata kuskil. Tahad kuvada? No, võin panna ju kuskile
Õpetaja: panengi. Noh, Teeme väikse tähe. Ei tule Back Endist niukest asja. Kui mina nüüd näiteks tulen ja otsin ülesse selle template osa.
Õpetaja: Kus on näiteks linna nimi, Kus kohas ma usun Tagide seest. Tag idest tagide vahel.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan siin öelda, et ma ei taha tekste kirjutada, vaid tahan kirjutada mingi muute nime
Õpetaja: Topelt Loogilised sulud või? Mina tahan viidata igal tsüklil selle Location objekti peale, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii ma tahan. Seda Kirjutan siia. Location.
Õpetaja: Näe, kogemata tuli, Onju Location.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan sügavamale minna sellel objektil
Õpetaja: punktiga? Nüüd ta pakub mulle siin praegu Location County. Näinud Ma panen pulli pärast selle,
Õpetaja: mis Siis mul siin on?
Õpetaja: Tühjust, Sest et ta ei leia midagi, Ta ei saa siia midagi panna,
Õpetaja: et peab aru saama et see Mudel on võetud meil teenuse pealt, teatud hetkel, mis tegelikult taustal toimetab. Ma võin. Ma võin nüüd panna ka teistpidi. No ma panen sinna Sellele City name siia plaanitud Onju
Õpetaja: City name tuleks Tallinn. Tallinn, Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Nii, kui ma kustutan selle mudeli ära.
Õpetaja: Näete, ma võtan kogu selle sisu ära ta endiselt töötab. Miks
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et seal seal taga on objektid ja massiiv. Ja seal on niuksed väljad olemas.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult see sisu on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ma võin siia kirjutada, et Locations Kui ma siia lehele saabun, on alguses väärtus truup.
Õpetaja: See on jaavascript Ülisavi Siin ju tüüp ei olegi. Enes.
Õpetaja: Alguses laetakse see leht. Ta saab endale nimeks. Sisuks saab truuk. Aga niipea kui käivitub meetod, respons, öeldakse, et sina saad uue sisu. Sina saad selle, mis server sulle niiöelda andis, siis see on see tegelik sisu siin. Sa võid siin leerotada, mida tahad, lihtsalt Muidugi ongi hea,
Õpetaja: Kui siin kõik on korrektsed asjad, Sest et progemine muutub ka keeruliseks. Ma võtan korra selle ära Vaata, selle uuesti selle Sisu.
Õpetaja: Ee, kustutan uuesti. Ära Noh, kui praegu seda sisu ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kui praegu seda sisu ei ole, siis kui ma tulen siia ülesse Progema näiteks. Vabandust alla, kui ma tulen siia progema, et. Hei, võta location I seest
Õpetaja: väli Noh, paku mulle midagi, mis ta ei paku Midagi
Õpetaja: ma ei ole kuidagi ära defineerinud. Mis seal Locations sees on? Ta teab, et see on massiiv, aga seal, tema teadmised lõppevad
Õpetaja: aga Nüüd ongi see, et kui meil on see mudel olemas
Õpetaja: Jah, ja kui see mudel on olemas, on kohe teine tera.
Õpetaja: Tulen siia, ütlen Location punkt ja ta pakub neid välja. See, mis seal on. Kas te saate mõttest aru?
Õpetaja: Need Asjad on omavahel seotud. Idea on see, Mis taustal mõistab seda Staffi, onju?
Õpetaja: Mitte see keel ise. Vaata praegu. Siin on ära progetud, et ta, kuidas ta neid asju mõistab.
Õpetaja: No Siin on see Location County Name. No selle ma saadan üldse pensionile. See oli lihtsalt näide,
Õpetaja: et need asjad tegelikult ei tähenda mitte midagi, Mida Siin, kirjutavad, kui taustal päriselt nii pole?
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ongi ülitähtis, et, ee,
Õpetaja: proovite ikka teha Üks Proovite raskusi seda progama teistpidi back end Kõigepealt võtate kindla mudelis vägerist vigu ei teki. No ainuke asi, mis peate meeles hoidma, on see, et kui te hakkate Back end is muutma. Ma ütlen praegu Tto klasse klassid, mis on mõeldud ee, andmete kandmiseks, mis muutuvad ka Jason Iks
Õpetaja: ee siis, kui te hakkate tegema Niiöelda Jaova klassides muudatusi, nimesid, asju lisate, kustutate. Te peate alati mõtlema, et kas see teenus on juba kasutusel, et te lähete muutma, Ma ei mõtle seda, et sa teed mingit uut asja. Ja sa seal kogu aeg midagi Muudad vaid et
Õpetaja: mingi asi on juba ammu olnud juba siin viis päeva tagasi tehtud või rohkem kauemgi veel. Sa lähed seda asja muutma. Sul peab kohe olema nagu see mõte. Oot, oot Oot, kui mina praegu siin Back end is teen muudatuse, siis Sellel on kindlasti frontendile, kus on juba ära progetud.
Õpetaja: Kui seda teenust veel ei tarbi keegi, Aga kasuta. Mine tee oma service klassid lahti. Vaata, kas seda üldse näed. Kuskil seal. Vaata, et on see ära progetud, Kui on, siis leiad kohe ülesse. Kus on ka tarbijad? On ju
Õpetaja: et siis sa pead arvestama, et ma lähen vaatan need kohad üle Ja Siis viin need muudatused ka vastavalt ellu. Nagu ma Backendis tegin. Muudatused. Võibolla teavitad viisakuses teisi inimesi ka veel. Vaata, et ee, tegid midagi ringi, aga juba tegid Frontist korda.
Õpetaja: Nii. City, Namage peaks tulema.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Tallinn Tallinn Tartu.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et töötab Järgmisena. On siis ee, Sikupilli. Prisma siin samamoodi. Topelt Loogilised sulud
Õpetaja: Location objektiga. Me suhtleme, Olid location paned punkt.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis siia tuleb?
Õpetaja: Location Name?
Õpetaja: Vaatame Refresh ja Fresh.
Õpetaja: See on nagu palgapäeval. Halvad uudised läinud. Ee, siin Ma vist kogemata olen midagi ära söönud. See nurgaline sulg on kaduma läinud.
Õpetaja: No Refresh Tikupilli prisma tundi. Selur Jääprisma on olemas.
Õpetaja: Sobib Ee, Nüüd on listiga Vaadake, mis ta nende mummudega tegi.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin on Text Alignment on vist Center või midagi taolist. Ma ei tea, miks ta niimoodi on.
Õpetaja: Ma praegu läheks lihtsamat teed pidi, et teeme siia tavalised Ee, Dv.
Õpetaja: Mine. Mina ei tea Ilusti. Sain. Oskan öelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme selle ul komponendi tervise. Lihtsalt Ee Divi sisse ja hetkel lihtsalt panen. Sisse.
Õpetaja: Teen korra praegu kõrvale ka tublikaadi välja. Lihtsalt et oleks korra midagi vaadata. Ta isegi ei pea seda tegema
Õpetaja: Noh, siis on vist veits, on parem, on ju
Õpetaja: Kogu see tabel on liiga liiga liiga lai. Esiteks, muidugi see Selleks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on küsimus samamoodi jälle. Vaata, et ee, Aga kuidas nüüd siis edasi?
Õpetaja: Sest et kogu see osa, mis on siin, peab tulema. Dünaamiliselt on nii,
Õpetaja: et igas ühes on üks üks, Aga tegelikult neid peab tulema. Nüüd, vastavalt nii palju, kui
Õpetaja: meil on siin Transaction Type sees. Objekte niuke, Väline nagu Transaction Types, mis on Omakorda massiiv
Õpetaja: Mis on teil mõtted? Ee, praegult siinkohas.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas saab dünaamiliselt uus luup puuluup. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kuu lõpuks just laulu teha Muidugi, et Igal real
Õpetaja: meil on kolm rida. Näiteks onju seal tabelis. Aga Igal real on veel omakorda massiivses teenuste osas.
Õpetaja: Need on eraldi objektid Vaatame. Uuesti.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra. Tegelikult, seda näidet on siin
Õpetaja: selle sees. Transaction types I sees on olemas omakorda.
Õpetaja: Okei, no selle otsustasime ära, et see Nii võiks olla
Õpetaja: siis siia Tv sisse võiks teha luubi, mis ma kirjutan? Siia?
Õpetaja: Vii We Four algus.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas meil on nagu, et Me jõuaksime mingi tulemuseni. Esialgu teeme väikse template.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk on küsimärk ning paremal pool peab viitama mingisugusele kollektsioonile.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted teil siin on?
Õpetaja: Keegi juba ütles midagi.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga kui ma hakkan kirjutama praegu Transaction ei tule, ei paku midagi.
Õpetaja: Jaa, täpselt vaata. Iga Zero on üks location Mida ta joonistab
Õpetaja: nüüd selle asemel, et me nagu siin me panime Location City, name ja Nii edasi.
Õpetaja: On ju location name ja Nii, edasi. Nüüd me lihtsalt viitame Location objektile. Location Punkt Transaction types on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, ja ma tulen ise keyboardiga siia tagasi. Ehk siis siia. Kirjutame kõigepealt Location punkt.
Õpetaja: Valime selle. Vaata, siin on tüübid. String String. Number number number siin. Ta ei oska tüüpi öelda sellepärast, et see Lihtsalt objekt
Õpetaja: Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Nüüd paremal pool on kollektsioon Vastable
Õpetaja: nüüd vasakule poole. On vaja mingisugust ee, muutuja nime mis võiks olla muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: Muidugi, lihtsalt ainsuses ei ole vaja kirjutada pikalt. Näiteks Location Transaction Type. Seda pole vaja. Ee, meil on see informatiivne.
Õpetaja: Tuled siia asemele, paned Põmaki maha.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, kuidas nüüd tabeleid näidatakse.
Õpetaja: Mm, okei,
Õpetaja: Midagi veel kuvatakse, onju küll. Praegult kõik. On see staatiline tekst sisse.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on siin.
Õpetaja: Me ju ei taha, et kõigil lihtsalt on sisse. Sisse, sisse, sisse, sisse. Saime aru, et raha sisse saab panna, aga äkki Tegelikult on seal mingi muu info.
Õpetaja: Topelt loogilised sulud. Tahame viidata mingisugusele objektile, mis objektile tahame viidata.
Õpetaja: Muidugi, see ainsus onju Transaction Type
Õpetaja: kui Terve selle sisu paned, siis tulevad mingisugused terve objekt.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei taha tervet objekti, mida meie tahame
Õpetaja: ja tahame kuvada nime.
Õpetaja: Nii, kas Te saite sellest mõttest aru? Meil on luubi. Sees
Õpetaja: kuulub. Mis sellest laulude klubi sees?
Õpetaja: Pärast anname maile ülesande et ta teeks sellest laulu, Aga nüüd on üks kombps.
Õpetaja: Midagi On siin natukene valesti või kindad Air, Aga midagi valesti. Mis on valesti
Õpetaja: Kui Taaski vaadata, siis tuleks see tekst välja, Aga ma panen need objektid korra siia, et ajutiselt korra ennast alles niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on? Mis on? Ee, mida, mida Peaks nagu teistmoodi Siin, olema.
Õpetaja: Täpselt, Ütle kõva häälega
Õpetaja: piisav eelõpel kontroll. Me ei taha. Me tahame näidata ainult seda, Kus on see piisav Eelpool on truu. Ehk siis sellest vaatest. Tegelikult peaks olema niimoodi, et. Ee. Meil on kolm rida, Kaks rida, Kaks rida, on nii?
Õpetaja: No Kuidas me saame, muidu? Kuidas me siiamaani oleme seda teinud? Ee, visuaalses pooles. Nagu näitan. Näita
Õpetaja: vee, If. Iga ahaa. Nüüd peaks nagu midagi kombineerima.
Õpetaja: Nüüd peaks kombineerima.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd. Siin vist tuleb üks Aa, väikene mure. Sisse Minu teada ei saa teha sellel samal V Foori niiöelda Tv ja sellel Aa ei saa teha korraga.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui Vf peaks justkui olema, siis ju terve Tv I ei näidata, siis me Peame oma konstruktsiooni natukene muutma,
Õpetaja: et me peame tekitama niimoodi, et meil, on eraldi.
Õpetaja: Võtke see sisukorra ära. Deliidiga vajutage. Meil on vaja veel ühte Tv I.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et me ei saa panna kahte tükki korraga Siin Real alles selgub. Vaata see, et mis siin selle objekti taga on, et teeme Tv I juurde.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: siia sisse võib panna selle väärtuse. No mis see väärtus oli? Kuidas seda sai teha? Me oleme, Kus ma. Kuidas ma praegu saan kirjutada, et tuleks jälle raha sisse, raha välja ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Topelt loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: Ütlen siia Transaction Type Ja Transaction Type name. Taastame korra selle olukorra, et neid nagu sisu näeme.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd siia Reale on küll võimalik kirjutada juba W Ifi.
Õpetaja: Noh, kirjutame siis siia. V If.
Õpetaja: Mida me tahame nüüd vaadata? See. See peab nüüd rehkenduma.
Õpetaja: Ja Anastasia ei
Õpetaja: anastassia. Sa oled õigel teel, Aga lihtsalt see lõpp läks nagu lappesse. Miks seda ei ole vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Me. Me võrdleme väärtust puuleniga ja paneme ta võrduma truuga. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Mm, vot, ee. Lähme vaatame korra siis. Ee, korra materjale.
Õpetaja: Tuletame Anastasiale ja mõnele teisele ka niikuinii. Keegi mõtles sama teha. Käsi püsti, kes mõtles sama,
Õpetaja: aga kõik teised teadsid. Vaata ennast siia. See see vestlus on ainult sulle personaalselt. Teised on juba nii, Advanced.
Õpetaja: Nad juba teadsid vaikselt. Kõik itsitasid pihku.
Õpetaja: Issand Jumal küll. Ta võrdleb truut truuga. Nagu
Õpetaja: niimoodi nad tegid. Ee Valid, klassiruumis. Ma ei mäleta, mis Ee, valid Ee, klassiruumis.
Õpetaja: Ee, teemade järgi. Ma vaatan kuskil Feb seitsmes Äkki võis see olla
Õpetaja: nii. Siin on tavaline If lause,
Õpetaja: kui sa teed If lause Ja sa üritad mingi muutujale väärtust anda.
Õpetaja: Nii et kui sa vaatad, et kui Role name, ei võrdun all, siis ta on truu, Siis sa üritad öelda mingile asjale, et tema väärtus on truu.
Õpetaja: Kui sa üritad, öelda et võrdune all ja ta on False siis False lähebki selle muutuseks. See see väärtus. Kas oleme nõus? Vaata, et sees
Õpetaja: Isabeli pilli enda sees ongi juba väärtus true,
Õpetaja: Ja kui see väärtus on true, siis seda asja kuvatakse. Kui see väärtus on False,
Õpetaja: siis seda kuvataksegi, et kui te kunagi võrdlete ee, true true ga nagu mõttes. Vaata, et ei tea, mis seal dünaamiliselt sees on. Siis on esimene vihje teile, et ei. Kui ma oleks võrdnud, et true ei võrdu Falls, siis on midagi ei muud. Siis on tagurpidi. Siis on. Siis Oleks vaja nagu mingit võrdlust teha.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: aga kui truu on Truu ja truu. Et kui siin on truu väärtus, siis näita. Siis. Meil ei olegi mitte midagi muud vaja teha. Noh, teised, jumal tänatud, Juba teadsid? Ee, Anastassia veel siin lonkab. Järgi meile niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, punased jooned. Pakkuge Miks on punased jooned? Lahendame need ka. Ära.
Õpetaja: Talle meeldi vaatamas. Keegi ei mäleta midagi, mis ma rääkisin. Täna vist vä. Täna rääkisin mis talle, meeldib.
Õpetaja: Point on see et nüüd, ongi ideaalne näide Vaadake seda objekti mastaapsust.
Õpetaja: Siin on päris palju informatsiooni Ja kui voe ise peaks taustal igat objekti nagu vaatama, et kas siin on toimunud Mingi muudatus või mitte, siis seal on nagu probleemid. Võibolla võivad tekkida ja need tekivad varem või hiljem.
Õpetaja: Me tahame lihtsalt, öelda, et ära Jälgi tervet seda listi listi. Niiöelda kõiki objekti individuaalselt. Ja hoia meeles, milline seis on ja jälgi. Kui muutus, tuleb renderda uuesti. Tahame talle lihtsalt öelda, et mina annan sulle niiöelda. Ee, nendes kohtades mingid unikaalsed väärtused, mida ainult esineb ühe korra.
Õpetaja: Eriti hea, kui nad on lihtsad Numbrilised väärtused, mida on hea võrrelda vaadata, et seal listis ja Location Id D, üks, kaks, kolm. Kui järsku midagi muutub. Üks, kaks, kolm, Neli järelikult. Mingi location on juurde tulnud ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Me siis peame minema sinna. Reale, kus see Four tsükkel on?
Õpetaja: Ja lisame siia juurde ühe atribuudi. Mis on?
Õpetaja: Kiiga nüüd on? Muidugi see konks, et kui ma hakkan siia midagi trükkima,
Õpetaja: vot mis? See, mis? Mis siin on vihje siin praegu.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: tekst on, on ju? Ta on string. Ma pean nüüd natukene nagu aitama. Et Ei, ma seekord ei, mõtle. Ee, tekstid Stringi. Mida ma ise sisse kirjutan? Vaid kooloniga. Ütlen, et see tuleb kuskilt muutujast Nüüd, kui ma olen siin Location Real,
Õpetaja: siis ma siia ütlen. Location punkt. Ja milline oleks nüüd ideaalne infokild, mida Voel saab jälgida Location Id,
Õpetaja: et kui tema loeb Üks, kaks, kolm, Üks, kaks, kolm, üks, kaks, kolm. On kogu aeg. Siis tema teab uuesti. Ei pea joonistama. Tuleb üks, kaks, kolm, neli, või tuleb lihtsalt Üks, kaks. Ta saab aru, et. Okei, nüüd midagi muutus. Järelikult ma pean renderdama kõik uuesti.
Õpetaja: No selle saime paika. Nüüd läheme selle teise tsükli juurde. Siia on ju samamoodi
Õpetaja: objekt. Siin iseenesest on grammi võrra kergem, et siin on natukene vähem staffi but non the less,
Õpetaja: tal on, ee, vaja Nagu raskust. Me teeme selle samamoodi. Panen siia. Tühike, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Pool ongi.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõte oli õige.
Õpetaja: Jah, et kõigepealt Ma viitan sellele objektile endale. On ju, Kus sees on see? Näete, siin on mingi asi, mille puhul otsustatakse näitaja. Ära näita, et mingi Sisuline pool. Mis tekst on? Nüüd läheb kolmas asi ka enda käiku. Vaata, on ju? Kui ma ütlen. Siin. Ee, Transaction Type,
Õpetaja: Igal tsüklil On üks objekt siin sees. Mind huvitab see, et vaata sina seda. Transaction Type Id küsib.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei olegi midagi. Nüüd peab küsima midagi. Jah, tead, see lõppu lähedal.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga see tuletas meelde. Vaata, et. Ee. Äkki teeme nüüd kohe varsti pausi? Mulle tundub, et me oleme Enamvähem, ee. Me ei ole päris jõudnud lõppusena natukene veel progeda, aga pausi peab niikuinii ära tegema.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis see keel praegult on?
Õpetaja: Kui Me teeme viisteist pinsa pausi, siis kell on. Aa, mis ta siis on? Ee, neliteist Kolmkümmend viis on ju.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui me teeme Täna Ka teeme kuusteist kümneni palju. Siis sinna jääb umbes? Küta? Minu me pea. Ei võta enam sorry
Õpetaja: tund pool tund kannatame niimoodi. Kas Teeme kohe pausi või teeme Kümne minuti pärast viieteist Minuti pärast
Õpetaja: jah. Me, saime nagu mingisuguse loogilise punkti ja. Pärast jätkame vaata. Onju, Kuidas Järgmine samm on see, et kuidas siis teha niimoodi, et kui ma siit midagi valin,
Õpetaja: et siis hakkab siin Action pihta on ju
Õpetaja: Davai. Ee, lõpp. Mm, nüüd me teeme,
Õpetaja: kui teeme. Jah, väga hea mõte.
Õpetaja: Tere, aga miti mitte, Bush? Teeme siis viisteist minuti pausi ja tuleme Värske peaga tagasi. Vahepeal üks kohvi.
Õpetaja: Oh, naised.
Õpetaja: Noh, vahel ka vä.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: jah, ma ei suuda neid seoseid ja väga kiiresti, aga et Noh, vigu ära keerad On
Õpetaja: endale. Ei käi enam järgi.
Õpetaja: Power Google.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ma tahan vaadata probleem. Mul on tema ära õppinud ränguga mingi kohale.
Õpetaja: Sa pead seda otsima kuulama. Seda räägib, onju?
Õpetaja: Mul on kümme teemat. On, edasi
Õpetaja: võibolla.
Õpetaja: Endale see. Teeb üks segada
Õpetaja: ei. Ole kolm Milleks
Õpetaja: kuidas vaadata?
Õpetaja: Aitäh,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Kahtlemata.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: minu arvates.
Õpetaja: Jah.
Õpetaja: Mul, on, ee, üks mõttes nii öelda.
Õpetaja: Koju. Vaata
Õpetaja: silma saate
Õpetaja: tuleks maha, et Vaata mhmh nädalavahetust hommikut.
Õpetaja: Mitu korda ütles niimoodi? Et ümber kümnendusega
Õpetaja: täpselt sama. Nagu kui inimene magab võistluses Lõpeb midagi öelda jah.
Õpetaja: Palun,
Õpetaja: vastupidi
Õpetaja: Väga optimaalne niimoodi võtta,
Õpetaja: onju?
Õpetaja: Järsku, saad aru?
Õpetaja: Programmi peal antud. Veel.
Õpetaja: Ja alati siis saad aru.
Õpetaja: Kõik teised, nagu läksid ära õnneks, nagu Tuleb alles.
Õpetaja: Aa, tuleb see viimane lõik.
Õpetaja: Nii ma praegu vaatasin rekordi. Paneme siis paus peale Kui puudu Mm
Õpetaja: tõuseme siis sinnamaani, et ee, Taustal tuuakse ära andmed ja kuvatakse kuvatakse ainult neid, mida vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, Create success.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on ee, natukene vaja seda veel timmida.
Õpetaja: Ee, Taask siis ütleb meile ka seda, et. Ee, see peab hakkama nüüd kä ee käituma selle peale.
Õpetaja: Lisa linna rippmenüü järgi andmete filtreerimine.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, Ma vaatan, kus kohast ta räägib. Aa, veaolukorra, et on lõpus. Siis tegeleme sellega Lõpus.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei kasutaja. Valib linnade rippmenüüst linna, mille peale käivitatakse, siis. Ee, see sama. Teenus. Andmete laadimine. Nii et andmete parimisele antakse kaasa City Id väärtus, mida me praegu oleme juba teinud, aga Mitte mis tuleb rippmenüüst, vaid tuletan meelde, et meil on siin Selle City Id algväärtus on null ja hetkel see läheb
Õpetaja: on, Nii no Kasutatakse siin. Ju seda.
Õpetaja: Ee Tuletan meelde ka seda, et.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil varasemalt Ee oli tehtud. Ee, see, kuidas seda kiirelt üles leida, Ee, Leian ta visuaalist kuskilt ülesse. Ta on vist kuskilpailus. Siin
Õpetaja: City Strop. Ta on
Õpetaja: tegelt. Ei ole isegi siia sisse vaja tulla, vaid saab juba vaadata. Kas on tehtud niimoodi, et oma sisu ta saab, Siis me toome kuskilt ära, on ju? Ja siis on Event New City Selected hetkel lihtsalt teeb seda,
Õpetaja: mis me saame. Nagu näha ka et see toimib.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et see väärtus tuleb sealt, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, alt ülesse. Meie viskab alergi, onju?
Õpetaja: On? Aga kõik, mis me nüüd siis peame tegema, on see, et hoopis see väärtus, mida me kasutame,
Õpetaja: tuleb. See tuleb siia Databloki City Id le anda
Õpetaja: ja lihtsalt käivitad uuesti. See Teenus, mis toob ära andmed. Kui andmed tuuakse ära, siis kuvatakse uut Tabelit, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, ongi.
Õpetaja: Siis alustaks sellega, et tehke teiega kaasa, et esiteks
Õpetaja: see meetodi nimi enam nagu väga hästi ei ei klapi.
Õpetaja: Mis see tegevus on? Vaata, mis meil on plaanis.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siis ee. Hägusalt. Ma teeksin niimoodi Ee, sest et siin on kaine Nagu Kaks asja, mida me teeme. Me anname City Id le uue väärtuse, mis on datablokis
Õpetaja: ja me käivitame uuesti selle teenuse, mis toob andmed ära. Mure on nüüd selles Nagu, et ükski meetodi nimi, mida ta absoluutselt ei tohi teha, on. Ta ei tohi valetada
Õpetaja: Meetodi nimi ei tohi valetada selles osas, et kahte pildi kuidas saab. Valetada. Üks variant on see, et. Ee. Ma ütlen, et ma teen kahte asja, Aga kui tegelikult vaatad koodi, siis sa näed, et ta teeb ainult ühte asja
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb, et ma teen mingisuguseid asju,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei Tee kõiki neid asju, mida meetodi nimetas. Teistpidi, Vastupidi ta ütleb, et ma teen ühe mingi kindla asja ära aga tegelikult meetodi sisse vaadates programmiliselt. Vaata, ta teeb mitut tegevust.
Õpetaja: Ühte ennast nina ei peegelda. Siis mina teeks niimoodi, et mina jätaksin selle meetodi nime.
Õpetaja: Noh, näiteks siit Ee, vaadates. Ee, häguseks.
Õpetaja: Olen juba varem ka nagu kasutanud ühte sõna, mis nagu hägusalt. Vahel võib aidata mingi olukordade Ee niiöelda realiseerimisel
Õpetaja: handle
Õpetaja: pannakse mingi Handle City trup.
Õpetaja: Saun Top Down Change Midagi taolist,
Õpetaja: sest et nüüd ta tegelikult ütleb, et ma lahendan seda, seda ei ütle, Kuidas meil ei olegi vaja teada, kuidas
Õpetaja: otseselt siin. Ei Ole vaja. Teada.
Õpetaja: Kui refaktorit küsib üle niimoodi, siis kiirelt vajutage refaktor, mida ta ei muuda, et see on kinnitust üldse.
Õpetaja: Handle City. Drop Down Change.
Õpetaja: Kutsume selle nime. Ära
Õpetaja: nüüd, selle alergi asemel, et City City Id tuleb sisse. Seda just ee, seal alergis näidati
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis on meie plaan.
Õpetaja: See siis peaks saama uue sisu
Õpetaja: ja peale seda oleks meil vaja käivitada See meetod
Õpetaja: Gate Locations, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, siis tulemegi siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Kuidas selle City Id ära muudame? Mis on datablokis, mis ma Kirjutan siis siit ja nii
Õpetaja: uut sisu saab anda. Mis sümboliga?
Õpetaja: Ja mis ma kirjutan? Kus ta oma väärtuse saab?
Õpetaja: No mängumaa, mingi muster Lühike
Õpetaja: Ju ta ju ta sellelt muutuvalt saab. On ju, et alt niiöelda vend käidab Ee, põhimõtteliselt alt. Ee City Event käivitab selle meetodi Ee, tuvipakiga tuleb kaasa City Id siin. Nüüd ongi see, et vaadake, need värvid mängivad. See on valge
Õpetaja: See on valge. Kui Minna City Id peale vaatama, siis City Id on lilla. On Violetna või roosa? Ma ei tea, kuidas te defineerite seda värvi,
Õpetaja: ehk siis kujutage, ette et. Noh, kui ma kommentaariga praegu siin seda kuidagi teeks, et et oletame, et siin
Õpetaja: on väärtus kaks
Õpetaja: ja siin on Väärtus City is Endas on väärtus null ja siin on kaks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd saab uue väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Kui see oleks ainult siukene meetod, et ainukene tegevus oleks see
Õpetaja: siis Selle meetodi nimi oleks Set City. Id.
Õpetaja: Jaavas on setter meetodid, mis ee niiöelda siis muudavad objekti väljade väärtuse.
Õpetaja: See oleks täielikult niukene. Aga Kuna nüüd on tegelikult vaja hoopis käivitada see Cat Locations,
Õpetaja: mis juba toob siis uue City Id väärtusega. See muutub siis ju kaheks on Ju
Õpetaja: Siis ei saa seda meetodit selliselt ee kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin saaks veel olla ka. Näiteks Niukene Update Ee locations table,
Õpetaja: mis on ka kirjeldav. Ma räägin, et nagu meetodi nimed võiakse, võiksid ka mingid muud olla,
Õpetaja: et alt tuleb. Alt tuleb niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla update asemel oleks Isegi veel parem reload ei loota. Allocation Stable
Õpetaja: või niiöelda äriloogilisemad nimed ei viita siis konkreetselt tabelile, Kuigi, noh, seda saaks teha, või Noh, Kuidas see komponendi nimi on? Vaata, vaatame, kuidas ta on. Aa, mis värk on? Ei olegi komponent.
Õpetaja: Aga kui taaski vaadata, noh, taaskis see kunagi. Nagu päriselt kirjas ei oleks.
Õpetaja: Ee Arendajale jäetakse ka ikka mingisugune. Ee, niiöelda oma vabadus ee teha asju nii nagu tema tahab,
Õpetaja: aga Siin on öeldud, et, ee. See võiks olla eraldi Tabeli komponent
Õpetaja: nimega Location Stable. See on meil on veel tegemata on ju
Õpetaja: õnneks siin Mingit interaktiivsust ei ole,
Õpetaja: et on ainult Kasutatud. Locations objekti ja kõik muud andmed tulevad Sellest seest aga ühtegi pole. Vaata, mis midagi teeks Ja mis oleks siin meetodi blokis? Ma nüüd näitan ära selle probleemi ka kohe. Ee, et miks see? Miks see, et kui juba visuaalne osa viitab meetoditele. Mis on siin klassis.
Õpetaja: Siis on selle ekstraktimine keerulisem. Sellepärast, et
Õpetaja: see meetod ja see tegevus peaks minema sinna samma klassi, Kuhu see strakitav kood läheb? Seal on see probleem. Ta ei oska neid tõsta. Niimoodi ringi, vaid ta teeb ühe keerulise süntaksi, mis on Täiesti ebavajalik.
Õpetaja: Kohe vaatame.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ee, meie siis tuleme siia. Kus meil see Handel City Drop. Down Change.
Õpetaja: Ega ma isegi tahaks ära muuta Seda loodame ära, paneme.
Õpetaja: Oota, mis asja nimi pidid olema? Location Stable paneks nagu Aa Reload Locations Table.
Õpetaja: Ja see on ka jälle Faktor ei meeldis. Tahab vajutada. Jällegi see on selline koht, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Noh, ütleme selle klassikalise Lause kellele tütar, kellele ema? Vaata, et mingid asjad on nagu maitse asi.
Õpetaja: Ee. Meetodi nime, et muutuja nimed klassi nimed Kohati võivad niimoodi olla. Et ee vahel on väga põhjendatud ja argumenteeritud, Näiteks, et miks mingi asi võiks mingi nimega olla. Või siis veelgi rohkem, et võibolla ütleme. Juunior paneb mingi nime ja siis seenior, nagu Ütleb, et Kuule, see on eksitav. Lausa,
Õpetaja: et võibolla argument, et kindlasti võib olla alati argument, et miks ei peaks olema niimoodi aga kuskil Seal Vahel on Niukene üsna hall ala.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kuidas mingid ee meetodi nimesid ja klassi nimesid ja muud nimesid panna. Niiöelda,
Õpetaja: see on ka täpselt see, et kui tuleks tagasi, siis kõige viimane koht, kus ma viitsiks üldse midagi vaielda, kui teine arendaja ütleb, et. Oi, oi, Oi, see meetodi nimi võiks olla mingi niukene.
Õpetaja: No ja kui ta oleks oma arvamus, las siis olla nii, nagu tema tahab, et mis Me nagu selle maitse üle vaidleme.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ei oska, ei oskaks justki väga veenvalt argumenteerida. Miks ma arvan ikkagi, et, ee, aga see Ei oleks see koht, nagu milleks see ongi. Seda on näha nagu see. Vaata, et, ee, pigem toimuvad kaklused Seenior Seenior versus Ee, juunior Ja seenior. No juuniorid, kes ei julge kakelda.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõned juuniorid on nii lollid, et nad hakkavad kaklema Tegelikult see on suur viga. Ajad Lihtsalt vihale inimest kes üritab sind õpetada ja sulle midagi rääkida.
Õpetaja: Ee, see oleks nagu erilist point. Võibolla seenior nagu niivõrd palju, lihtsalt rohkem kogemust. Ee, et ee, et seal võib juhtuda see, et sul on illusioon asjast. Vaata, et mul on õigus,
Õpetaja: aga sa tegelikult ikka veel ei jaga mingisugust väiksemaid peenemaid nüansse. Mida see inimene, kes on juba
Õpetaja: tuhat ee tuhat kilomeetrit koodi kirjutanud, onju, igasuguseid asju näinud,
Õpetaja: Ee, aga Seeniorid omavahel läheb ka karupidi kokku. Vaatas et seal, on juba välja kujunenud uskumused arvamused, mis on õige.
Õpetaja: See on nagu põhimõtteliselt, siis nagu Naisega vestlus. Vaata, onju, et. Ee, tal on alati õigus. Tegelikult seenioril.
Õpetaja: Ee vahet pole. Kas siis jääb
Õpetaja: no päriselus? Muidugi, nii, lihtsalt naisele Kõik Ei, kingi. Vaata, et natuke võitlema. Ka
Õpetaja: Ee, siin. Me tahame siis käivitada seda sama ee, sõnumit uuesti. Lihtsalt Gat Locations
Õpetaja: ja kõik Võiks töötada kui maagia.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, kas töötab. Et see ju nii on, et kui kontrollime üle,
Õpetaja: kui Alt City Strop Town Ist tuleb Event New City Selected
Õpetaja: toimub. Ee, pakikene Linnud püütakse kinni, Väärtustatakse see Data bloki käivitatakse meetod Cat Locations. Meetod käivitab Location Services kaasa. Antakse Sama City Id, mis muutus,
Õpetaja: kui kõik läheb hästi. Locations Respons Locations Objekt saab uued andmed, mis tulevad pakendist Circle Complete.
Õpetaja: No proovime alguses tuuakse kõik ee linnad ära. Niiöelda nulliga Mitte kõik linnad, vaid ka pangaautomaadid.
Õpetaja: Kui ma. Olin ee, Tartu
Õpetaja: midagi ei juhtunud.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: ma oleks praegu hakanud otsima. Kuidagi aitäh. Sulle oleks teinud siin jälle piinlikkust. Aga loomulikult, Stoplight vastab kogu aeg samamoodi. Aga
Õpetaja: it doesn that to be That või
Õpetaja: kui teeme korra stoplight I lahti.
Õpetaja: Nii palju Kas teil on ka sama olukord, et sellel on mingi elu nagu päris pikalt käinud.
Õpetaja: Ma ei leia enam asju üles. Nii, ee, loomulikult. Ma korra Nüüd vaatan üle, kus seal need teenused.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me tuleme, vaatame Siis seda location teenust
Õpetaja: Get Locations, ta on Kas ta pangaautomaatide asukohtade infot?
Õpetaja: See sama teenus. Kui Ma panen Moki peale,
Õpetaja: et kui ma Vaatan nagu seda, et, ee. Mismoodi? Ma pean sõnumit saatma. Et Ee,
Õpetaja: saada üht või teist tulemust.
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad on väga lihtne. Uuesti
Õpetaja: peab Header isse panema. Prefair kakssada.
Õpetaja: Sambel null.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis need teised näited on.
Õpetaja: Teised näited on null kaks ja kolm.
Õpetaja: Oota Mõtlesite aru, et Me saame siin samamoodi teha. Üks näidendang oli just puudu, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ei ole sellepärast, et ee. Number üks ehk pärnu peab ütlema, et ei leidnud ühtegi pangaautomaati. See on meil selle näite all.
Õpetaja: Nelisada, neli, üks.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Meie sisendid saavad olla nullist kolmeni. Ee, lihtsalt siis Ee, üks nendest peab saatma.
Õpetaja: Oota, ma vaatan korra. Kas selles ongi lihtsalt see sama number Siin põhimõtteliselt kordub a nelisada. Neli on ka, Okei, ee, võibolla. See on vaatamise koht. Ma Võin teile selle koodi anda Või Võite järgi tulla? Kes tahab kaasa ka teha, aga ma Eriti ootama ei hakkaks. See koht, kus see sõnumi saatmine toimub. Ma panen sinna väikse. Äkki peab ukse kinni sealt tagantpoolt karli Äkki sa. Paned
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidagi natukene Häirivamaks on muutunud
Õpetaja: see teenus siin võtab praegu sisse. Paramse.
Õpetaja: Minu mõte on see, et. Aga teeme niimoodi
Õpetaja: ennem, kui Me hakkame üldse siin toimetama.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus me tegime? Tegime ka sama asja, on ju? Mäletate seda kokku panemist?
Õpetaja: Ma teen kopin selle siit samast
Õpetaja: ja tulen siia. Location Service. Panen siia ja ütlen, et kui
Õpetaja: need asjad, ma vahetan, ära. Siin Control r mind and Replace, et Kui City Id võrdub City Id,
Õpetaja: Jah, City Id võrdub. Jah. Ee, Kui City Id võrdub ee null, siis soovin eksamblid null,
Õpetaja: kui City Id on Ee ee. Mis oli veel null? Kaks ja kolm olid. On ju?
Õpetaja: Kui City Id on niimoodi null vaid kaks, siis anna, Eksempel kaks.
Õpetaja: Teen korra ühe sektsiooni juurde siia,
Õpetaja: kui ütlen, et City Id on kolm.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga siin on valesti läinud. Nii
Õpetaja: nii null, Kaks ja kolm on valiidsed asjad. Kus on kahesaja ja vastava näite.
Õpetaja: Kõikidel teistel juhtudel Ütlen. Et ta on Ee Nelisada, Nelisada, neli või Nelisada, kolm, nelisada, neli.
Õpetaja: Cannot Found on, ee. Põhimõtteliselt nelisada. Neli ja Example on üks
Õpetaja: klapib Onju kõike. Numbrid on korra. On nii
Õpetaja: nüüd Põhimõtteliselt sellega saab siis ee, teha seda dünaamilisust,
Õpetaja: et iga kord, kui ta jõuab, veel ei saa, parems, on ka puudu. Vaata, on ju, et me lõime selle muutuja. Mis saab oma sisu vastavalt selle City Id le
Õpetaja: seda võibolla saaks üldse asendada Switchiga. Ma mõtlen, nagu, ee,
Õpetaja: ei paku praegu natuke. Ma ei viitsi mõelda. Jumal temaga. Ee, Siis
Õpetaja: siia vaja öelda ka, et. Ee. Mina soovin seda osa. Vaata, headers Reflöör välja.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle. Kuidas ma panen juurde koma? Ilmselt panen siia nende kahe vahele.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, panen Commit. I Tulge siis kõik järgi Kes tahavad seda katsetada.
Õpetaja: Või kui te tulete hiljem järgi, siis see on ka fine. Vaata, et, ee, seda pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Bussin selle igal juhul ära ja siis. Ee. Hakka kohe proovima ka.
Õpetaja: Buss pluss buss.
Õpetaja: Noh, seitse rida teksti. Siis saab pilve lükata.
Õpetaja: Nii läks saate Mina Samal ajal saan juba siis lihtsalt proovida.
Õpetaja: Tallinn Tartu üheksa Refresh I. Midagi ei toimunud. Tallinn,
Õpetaja: muidu peab ikkagi hakkama. Kõigepealt sellega Äkki mul On ee. Tuleb koguaeg ikka sama vastus, et nende inflausetega midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen pärnu, läks City Id üks Tartu City, Id kolm Tallinn Kogu aeg lähevad, aga failivad.
Õpetaja: Tema kogu aeg vastab mulle. Aga ta vastab kogu aeg mulle sama vastusega.
Õpetaja: See päris error nagu nelisada Not found. Siis on Minu mõte on see, et, ee, kus see asi nagu valeks läheb?
Õpetaja: Ta jõuab kogu aeg ehk City Id ei ole kunagi ükski nendest väärtustest mis justkui siin on,
Õpetaja: Siis ma pakun seda, et kas see on mingi numbri ja stringi teema?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma Korra mõtlen kõik, mis tuleb sealt. Ee, väljust peakski olema ju number. Aga äkki ei ole. Teate, milles on konksve?
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame korra seda Et, ee. Kui mina tulen siia poeblokki ja ma vaatan, et mis mul täpselt läheb. Siia City Id Ks,
Õpetaja: Siin City Id on null, Mis ta, on praegult null? Kui
Õpetaja: ma värvi järgi tunnen ära tee seda. Ei tea, ma teen korra Refresh i alg väärtus meil tegelikult On Pro programmiliselt näha,
Õpetaja: et on number. Null on ju? On ju? Ta ei ole ju stringide niiöelda nende üksikülakomade sees.
Õpetaja: Kui ma siia Alguses tulen. Siis Ta on sinine null. See tähistab see, et ta on päriselt number.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd korra vahetan, ära ja lähen Tallinna Peale
Õpetaja: korra pean klikima ta vahele. Ja Refresh I. Mis Tema väärtus on?
Õpetaja: Kaks. Aga kui vaadata Editit, siis ta on
Õpetaja: String Kaks Ee, Mäletate, ma rääkisin seda, et näiteks kui võtta, ee, kui võtta niiöelda sealt Mm,
Õpetaja: inputkastist, kus isegi tüüp on niiöelda ära määratud ee, number Sa tegelikult ikka võtab strengi. Noh,
Õpetaja: ta praegult endiselt sealt sellest väljust tegelikult saab väärtusi. Kui String Ina,
Õpetaja: siis meie ülesanne on nüüd niimoodi leida kõige esimene koht ülesse. Ee, kus me saaksime selle numbri niiöelda Tegelikult muuta numbriks,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, ta on tekst, aga me nüüd survestame, et. Oot, oot, ei, ei, see nüüd on nagu päris number. Mitte string ja null.
Õpetaja: Ee, Siis
Õpetaja: Meil tasub minna sinna kohta, kus seda Väljud emiititakse, sest see on kõige esimene koht, kus üldse nagu see number on. Ühel või teisel viisil seotud
Õpetaja: Ee, see tähendab seda, et Me peame minema, siis.
Õpetaja: Ee. Komponenti Näete seda seda kohta siit, kus paksadetakse teele?
Õpetaja: Siin ta praegult tuleb? Sellest väljust ja ta läheb, kui number.
Õpetaja: Mida me saame siis teha?
Õpetaja: Vot see on nagu veider asi. Kui me paneme selle väärtuse siia taha elama, siis ta tegelikult on seal taustal, kui number ta on. Number Aga kui me küsime selle? See vend Target value, saab ta ikkagi Stringina.
Õpetaja: Aa, kas jaavas Niukene Asi tuleb meelde. Konstruktor?
Õpetaja: Kuidas konstruktor töötas?
Õpetaja: Ma teen korra notepad I lahti.
Õpetaja: Kohe õue Lehe juurde kui minul on näiteks Ee, Public ee, Public Class ja student.
Õpetaja: Oi, ma tahtsin. Võib. Kontroll. Näed, juba vajutad nuppe, Mis on intellid sees,
Õpetaja: Kui meil on mingi. Mul on siin Näiteks Private.
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme siis first name.
Õpetaja: Nii, palun siis temal. Tegelikult. Taustal on selline meetod nagu public, vaid
Õpetaja: midagi tagastada, lihtsalt teeb uue Objekti student.
Õpetaja: Nüüd sulgudes kohe. Täidan selle sisu ka ära.
Õpetaja: Niukene meetod on tegelikult selle klassi sees.
Õpetaja: Selle asi on konstruktor.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seda võimalik on käivitada, on see, et kui ma kuskil mujal poodifailis ütlen New Tudeng,
Õpetaja: siis see tekitab objekti sellest klassist,
Õpetaja: kui minul on Niukene välisel Selle objekti sees Nagu first name. Näiteks siis mina saan teha niukse konstruktori
Õpetaja: mis ootab sisse. See on nagu javascriptis Led First name,
Õpetaja: et Seda asja on võimalik käivitada. First Name ja vaadake, kuidas see siis toimiks. Mina nüüd tahan niimoodi, et see konstruktor võtab selle muutuja väärtuse ja paneb selle objekti muutuja külge. Nüüd mul on täpselt sama olukord. Segadus on ju,
Õpetaja: et kaks korda on seda sama asja viidatud, ma ei saa öelda Siin niimoodi. Ei anna ile uus väärtus First name. Ehk siis ma ei saa öelda. Ei, anna sellele See väärtus siin Koodi lõigus.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlen siia ette.
Õpetaja: Ahah, tuleb tuttav ette.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ei, ole enam Confusion It. See first Name viitab sellele, on nii
Õpetaja: Ja see First name, mis on siin? Parameeter viitab sellele saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: nad läbi. Pead Ja nüüd New Student. Kui mina kirjutaks New student. I Viskaksin siia sisse mingisuguse väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Ai, siis tuleb sellest klassist uus objekt kus First Name on väärtusega Rain, sest käivitub selline meetod.
Õpetaja: Miks ma sellest nüüd jääpin? On see meie siin? Ütleme New student
Õpetaja: ja anname mingi sisu, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd kuidas seda saab teha Java Script is on see, et see on natukene poes. Lühendatud variant, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma käivitan konstruktori number, mis võtab sisse stringi kujul mingisuguse väljundi, näiteks Üks
Õpetaja: Ja tema taustal. Nüüd programmeeritud osas teeb sellest number objekti samamoodi. Nagu Teeb student teeb student ist objekti.
Õpetaja: See Nüüd teeb number objekti.
Õpetaja: Kui see rehkendub, siis juba päris numbriks. Üks saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie oleme siin koodi lõigus. Vaata kus. Me, ütleme, et anna mulle pakikene ja pane see tee limitiga,
Õpetaja: mida meie tahame teha. Me selekteerime selle osa ja võtame korra mällu. Kontroll X.
Õpetaja: Me nüüd kirjutame suure Tähenda selle tüübi number.
Õpetaja: Pilt inne, et see on juba sisse tehtud ja paneme sulud.
Õpetaja: Kui sina paned siia, Näed, ta võtab Any Type Value ei ole kohustuslik. Aga
Õpetaja: kui sa paned siia mingi koma kohaga? See vist on nagu raske. Ma ei tea, kas ta puuleni oskaks teha, siis tõesti. Numbriks on null. Truu on üks aegas, Aga põhiline mõte on see, et kui mina panen siia nüüd aimese panna üks nendega.
Õpetaja: Kui mina panen siia mingisuguse numbri, siis ta päriselt teeb selle numbriks.
Õpetaja: Aga mina ei taha siia nüüd numbrid panna, vaid mina ütlen, Nüüd võta see välju ja tee see numbriks.
Õpetaja: Mm, see asi. See käib, niimoodi et kood tuleb siia. Ta tahab seda asja rehkendada.
Õpetaja: Siis Ta vaatab kõigepealt. Oot, oot, mis see on? Ahah, selle ma saan kätte See on string nimega, mitte nimega, vaid number Üks
Õpetaja: Strings Sisuga Üks strings sisuga. Kaks Nüüd veel ei lähe. Vaata, mitte tööle ja mitte. Vaata, sul hakkab niimoodi pihta. Vaata, toimub Change
Õpetaja: kui toimub, Change käivitub ja mitmeid
Õpetaja: Tal on siin. Ee, kohustuslikud sise sisendid olemas, nagu mis me oleme ette kirjutanud. Ta näeb ära et ja ja Ja Ja Ja Niukene vend nimi.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta tahab paki teele panna. Tal on niimoodi. Oot, oot, ma ei saa seda pakki veel teele panna, et. Ee, siin on Kutsutud välja number. Ma ei saa seda ennem numbriks teha. Ma kõigepealt rehkendan selle välja. Saan selle numbriks
Õpetaja: panen kaks.
Õpetaja: Ma panen üksiküla komadega. Praegu rehkendan. Mingi numbri.
Õpetaja: Rehkendab selle sisu ära. Event Target. Value saab selle kätte. Rehkendab selle ära numbriks kaks Ja nüüd läheb ju mitte veel alles.
Õpetaja: Siin on sõltuvusjärjekord. Vaata, kuidas programm seda asja vaatab.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame nüüd meie. Kas see asi töötab lihtlabaselt. Kontrollin seda samamoodi selle poe tööriistaga. Teeme korra Refresh I ka.
Õpetaja: Algväärtus.
Õpetaja: On Sellel. City L on null Sinine. Number ei ole siin neid stringe.
Õpetaja: Kui ma muudan seda linna, panen tallinn
Õpetaja: Klikin korra mujale. See on renderdamise issue Sa ei uue väärtuse on number,
Õpetaja: tuli nüüd Need If laused. Nüüd vaata, probleem. Oligi selles, et. Ee, meil see sama asi. Kui ma oleksin teinud praegu selle hookuspookuse ära,
Õpetaja: siis see oleks juba ennem töötanud Sellepärast, et City Id tuli kogu aeg sisse. Stringina String null, String, kaks, string, kolm.
Õpetaja: Aga mul oli tüübikindel kontrollimine. Siis kas dring null võrdub nulliga? Ei võrdu. Kas string null võrdub kahega? Ei, võrd. Oh, kas kolm võrdub Kolmega? Ei, võrdu. Ei, võrdub Kogu aeg tuli see, et
Õpetaja: ei saa, ei saa. Ei leidnud sellist pangaautomaati. Saate, Mõtlesid aru, mis juhtus?
Õpetaja: See oli siis see, nagu see pugi. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja seda asja me hakkame pidevalt tegema. Kui me võtame kuskilt numbrilisi väärtusi. Esimene mõte peaks kohe olema. Ma võtan selle kuskilt Html vormilt, et tegelikult on
Õpetaja: streng.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole see tüüp, mis seal on.
Õpetaja: Ee, justkui Ideeliselt, No nüüd töötab Noh,
Õpetaja: ee. See osa vähemalt töötab, kui ma panen Tartu Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad pärnu
Õpetaja: töötab, aga ei tööta korrektselt, Sellepärast, et pärnu kohta tuli Nelisada. Neli No Location Found
Õpetaja: pole jõudnud seda veel progeda.
Õpetaja: Aga kui vaadata taaski, siis see. Meil järgmine asi ongi.
Õpetaja: Linnade rippmenüü
Õpetaja: vea vastusega. Error kood No location found Status nelisada. Neli kirjeldavat teksti ei ole. Juures Aga idee järgi võiks siis kahte asja vaadata
Õpetaja: staatust koodi ja error koodi,
Õpetaja: Kuna me. Kuigi Kuna meil tegelikult rakenduses kõik. Aa, meil on nagu ära programmeeritud, et kõik vastused tule kõik error vead tulevad sellise struktuuri Jasoniga. Siis Tegelikult saab ka lihtsalt vaadata seda error koodi väärtust. Põhimõtteliselt ainult.
Õpetaja: Aga mina ikkagi vaataks Ee, ennem status koodi
Õpetaja: ja siis ma Vaataks need mõlemad korraga, et kas Error Cood on Allocation Found Message tuleb siis tuleb edasi anda elektrika pangaautomaate. Teeme siis ee,
Õpetaja: Ega ma siin midagi muud ei teinud. Kui tegin, ainult, siis selle korda. Selle numbri osa. Te vist tegite ka selle kaasa. Ma eeldan,
Õpetaja: ee, nii et teil On see olemas või tuleb keegi järgi praegu.
Õpetaja: Võibolla seal oli mingi väike Delay. Ee, kas me. Kas me spinneri paneme või Piisab sellest ühest näitest, mis varem oli?
Õpetaja: Jah, ei, ikka on väsinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, mõte on see, et kui andmed laevad, vaata, et ta võtab hetk aega. Vaata siis me praegu kasutaja Ei saa. Üldse mitte midagi. Aru. Vaata, et ta peab midagi ootama.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda saaks teha.
Õpetaja: Ma võin öelda.
Õpetaja: No, need rumalad küsimused on alati teretulnud.
Õpetaja: See oli see, et et ei ole olemas, On ju Aga stand up i vastus,
Õpetaja: kohe.
Õpetaja: Mhmh
Õpetaja: Ei, ta teeb vahet ikka selles mõttes, et kui sulle If ta teeb vahet. Vaata siis, kui sul tuleb If Lause ja Tuleb mingi võrdlus. Kas on kolm võrdlusmärki või kaks? Selles mõttes vahet ikka.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma mõtlen, tema seda mõjutab palju rohkem.
Õpetaja: Kompilaator saadab su puhkama. Kui sa üritad erinevaid tüüpe asju võrrelda
Õpetaja: suudab. Aga ainult siis, kui sa teed seda kahe võrdlusmärgiga kolme asemel. See kolmas ütlebki, et Mõlemad tüübid peavad olema võrdsed ja siis on alles see, et sisuliselt, ee. Nad on sama väärtusega, et kui ma tahaks selle sama olukorra Tegin ära. Ma saan roll. Back. Ida on ju? Ee, et vaatame korra, et praegu töötab,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siit. Ee, tallinn,
Õpetaja: proovime Tartu, Need kaks on lihtsad, onju? Kui ma tulen tagasi korra sinna kohta, kus me siis nagu manipuleerime.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda tulemust, kui ma siit võtan Ära Need
Õpetaja: võtan need osad ära. Nüüd on niimoodi, et ta vaatab. Kas mõlemad pooled on sama väärtusega olenemata tüübist. Ta siis automaatselt on The Fly. Kui ma lähen City Strop Town I Võtan selle number osa ära vaata Onju, nüüd. On niimoodi et, tegelikult läheb string Onju, Nüüd Ta võiks tegelikult idee järgi justkui töötada. Teeme Refresh,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen Tallinn Tardo.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma vaataks siit praegu inspektiga, vaata siis Tegelikult City. Id all on meil number
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd ongi see. Vot see ongi. Just. See on nagu see ehe näide, nagu, et ee, Kuidas
Õpetaja: on võimalik, nagu see, et ta ise automaatselt siis rehkendab mõlemad pooled samasse tüüpi,
Õpetaja: et kuidas ta taustal teeb, et Kas ta teeb selle nulli siis nagu taustal teeb Ee, stringiks nulli või siis City Id väärtuse teeb just vastupidi numbriks. Seda ma ei tea peast, aga Seal Vahet pole, ta lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee. Ühel või teisel viisil viib mõlemad pooled ühele tüübile Enda arusaamise järgi. Siis saab sealt selle väärtuse, mis võib igasugust imelikku vigu. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: igast, mis kohas
Õpetaja: seal. Me suudame puhastada, kui ma nüüd väljendatud, eksole.
Õpetaja: Need kohad, kus ee, kus kohas Seda niimoodi tüübikindlalt ei võrdla.
Õpetaja: Aga vaata, sul võib igast muud asjad tulla. Näiteks et. Noh, aga milles on mingeid muid asju ka, Vaata, onju, et äkki see võrdlus ei olegi üldse võrdlusega. Ja nüüd oskab samamoodi. Ilmselt kui ma vaatan, kas üks on suurem kui teine, Vaata, onju, kuidas ta nüüd siin käitub, eksole?
Õpetaja: On see mõte ka? Vaata ikkagi, ta teeb ikkagi seda sama, sest et kuidas seda tüübikindlat on üldse võimalik teha. Ma ei teagi Vaata, mis juhtub.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma panen mingi muu asja, ma panen. Lase võrdne olla. Ma panen, et käivituks see põhimõtteliselt, et kui City Id on just selle, vaata, siis see kohe. Esimene käivitubki.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, kui on suurem
Õpetaja: kui on Suurem kui null, Põhimõtteliselt kõik asjad peale kõik linnad on ju mingi väärtusega peaks käivituma, et anna mulle kõik linnad,
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on ju Selline asi. Vaata, et. Ee. Vaata. Ma ei tea, kuidas see asi töötab. Tüübikindlalt või tüübitundetult.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, kui ma teen Refresh I ära, panen Kõik linnad Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Tallinn on esimene number. Vaata kõikidega peaks. Kord mõtlen selle eest. Ära. Kõikidega peaks olema sama tulemus. Kogu aeg,
Õpetaja: Tundub et töötab.
Õpetaja: Aga jällegi, nagu ma ütlesin, et. Noh, juba annab sulle märku. Vaata, et, ee. Sa ei peaks tegema üldse nagu niukest võrdlust, kus sa tüüpi ei vaata, et see võib producerida igasuguseid anomaaliaid, et nagu selleks, nagu peaks olema kuidagi väga põhjendatud. Ee, nagu otsus
Õpetaja: ee teha seda niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aga jaavas oleks niimoodi, et java ei luba koodi kirjutamise hetkel. No ütleme siis niimoodi. Ee, juba kirjutamise hetkel ütleb ära, et et sa üritad vaadata. Üks on suurem Kui teine. Vaata, üks on, siis trend. Teine on number, et nagu, nagu,
Õpetaja: ja selles mõttes, see Raamistik on nagu Fun Vaata, et taustal. Tegelikult siin see poe. Enda lahendused on pigem.
Õpetaja: Kus tüübid on? Ära defineeritud Onju, et see raamistik on eh. Raamistik on ehitatud peale ära, on ju? Aga siin saab toimetada Ma arvan, et ikkagi enamus projektid, mis praegult, tõesti nagu täna, Nagu alustaksid need projektid, mis alles sünnivad. Ja algavad ja on täiesti uus projekt. Neid kutsutakse Greenfield
Õpetaja: Projektid või et need on nagu niuksed Projektid, millest kõik arendajad õudsalt tahaks kaasa lüüa. Tavaliselt, sest kui sa oled kuskil ettevõttes, kus sa nagu kogu aeg lihtsalt täiendad seal mingit olemasolevat toodet, Siis see on nagu põnev, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja Kõik uued Ee, uued projektid Ma pakun. Pigem eelistatakse kindlasti typestreipi. Ma ei näe väga Palju põhjust, Miks spetsiaalselt?
Õpetaja: See lihtsalt see ekstra kindlus ja tööriistadega kontrollitavus. Kõik see, mis sa saad nagu sealt lihtsalt kaalub üle selle väikese Ebamugavuse peab koodi veidikene veel rohkem kirjutama.
Õpetaja: Aga õpetada ma seda ei tahaks, sest et see Syntax on veelgi kiirem,
Õpetaja: saate tüübikindlad programist niikuinii Jaavas proovida. Nii et selles mõttes vähemalt pole, ee, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Noh, no tegelt on ju siin isegi. Raskus. Vaata, nende samade lihtsamate asjadega, et meetodil on parameetrid. Miks nad on? On ju, et kui on mingeid andmeid vaja, saaks nagu need kontseptsioonid enam paika.
Õpetaja: Te saate kindlasti Kui te läheksite töökeskkonda, siis sealt, Nagu õppida juurde, nagu ei ole midagi erilist. Eriti kui juba jaava kogemus on ka selleks hetkeks selja taga, et see kontseptsioon nagu on Fun õppida. Sellepärast, et ma ütlen, et see on palju kirjum. Märksa kirjum on Ee type script.
Õpetaja: Okei, Ee, toimetame edasi, Mis järgmiseks?
Õpetaja: Ja tegin viimase push I.
Õpetaja: Mis veel?
Õpetaja: Aa, errorid on meil ju tegemata. Siin on ju,
Õpetaja: sest, et öeldakse, Ee, et kui on mingi näiteks pärnu, mille asukohta pole olemas, peaks tulema siia. Teade.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda sama taas ka ütles Vaataja, et ee. Veateates on kirjas.
Õpetaja: No Location Phounds on nelisada. Neli ei leitata ühtegi pangaautomaati.
Õpetaja: No, kust me kirjutama hakkame? Kui vaadata üldse minu koodiridu kus Me alustame
Õpetaja: tuuakse asukohad ära, aga tuleb mingi viga.
Õpetaja: Viiskümmend kuus siin. On See Catchblock. No kuidas see Catchblock töötab? Miks Millal see käivitub See Catchblock.
Õpetaja: Noh, natuke tehnilisemalt
Õpetaja: nelisada.
Õpetaja: Kui on vaadatav koodid mis algavad neljasaja või viiesajaga,
Õpetaja: siis automaatselt käivitub. No Meil ongi öeldud, et ee Teatud olukorras Server viskab siis nelisada. Neli.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on jälle see landase ee funktsioon vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Tema Ütleb minule see kontroll tühikuga Sai seda Cold Computation It.
Õpetaja: Tuled siia sisse ja valid.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga selle asemel võiks öelda error,
Õpetaja: Kui me siin ütlesime, et ee, midagi ta Hand Ib, siis. Ee. See meetod võiks olla põhimõtteliselt sama. Aga siin selle responsi juures võiks olla errorespons.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis kutsume välja meetodid mida pole veel olemas. Lihtsalt töövõte andal
Õpetaja: Get Locations Response. Ma juba tab iga. Valisin selle ära, aga tulen. Mudin seda
Õpetaja: ennem. Me valisime ka Niukse lahenduse
Õpetaja: nüüd siin. Kas nüüd võib sellest teha uue meetodi sulud? Panin ära
Õpetaja: niivõrd Kuidas mi? Aga miks see on vajalik
Õpetaja: Sest see On see sisu? Vaata, meil ei ole mitte mingisugust selle error I sees ongi kogu informatsioon, et kas ta on nelisada? Neli ja no Location. Kogu see nagu hea muusika, Onju, et see meetod respons ei tea oma välisest elust tööd, aga mütse see error praegult ainult siin
Õpetaja: Sellel hetkel ee. See sildikene tekib peal viiskümmend kuus ja tema sureb siin. Ja kui me tahame käivitada mingit muud koodilõiku ja me tahame seda infot kaasa anda, siis täpselt nii peabki tegema.
Õpetaja: Näed, kui ma hakkad siia kirjutama seda errori, siis ta pakub nagu paragrahv Või Parameeter On ju
Õpetaja: nüüd Seda meetodit pole? Tuleb selle kollase joone peale. Lihtsalt kuskile. Ütleb, et kas loome siis sellise meetodi? Tavai sobib? Sobib
Õpetaja: Tegi siia alla. Selle meetodi
Õpetaja: tegi niimoodi, et Return Ib midagi. Noh, tema ei tea, et meil seda plaani pole.
Õpetaja: Response.
Õpetaja: No, siin on nüüd Samamoodi nagu ennegi on see, et ee, esimene tegevus alati võiks olla see, et paneme selle informatsiooni,
Õpetaja: mis tuleb meil vastusena, Paneme ta kuskile elama,
Õpetaja: et mis iganes siit tuleb, meil oleks vaja lihtsalt mudelit, et me saaks koodis ka aru, et nagu, et mis siit teoreetiliselt siis saab tulla. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Tuleme. Võtame jälle selle sisu. Me võime natukene cheatida. Ee, lähme siis korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea Vaatame, mis vaade meil oli. Ee, Login View sse.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle data blokist. Ee, selle ära. See osa siin.
Õpetaja: Login just viitsi seda uuesti teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui teeks voest teeks Composition api kirjaviisi, siis saaks sellest teha. Niukse
Õpetaja: kind on nagu eraldi komponendi, mida saab taaskasutada, aga meie Seda lähenemist ei kasuta me lihtsalt Iga kord. Peame selle bloki uuesti tegema.
Õpetaja: Tulge kopiga See ja siis lihtsalt Adams View all. Otsime ka Data blokist.
Õpetaja: Mingi koha kuda võiks sobida. Vaadake, siin on need. Need on rainb niuksed. Jooned need On jooned ide poolt, aga värviliselt, ka et Vaadake, kust. Nagu üks või teine asi, nagu lõppeb, on ju, et ee kust, saab nagu uue teha, et leiame siin vaba ruumi. Siis kui lööd siia mingi uue rea, siis on vale,
Õpetaja: et see peab olema. Kus Locations lõpeb? Ütleme kaks korda. Entrid. Nüüd on mingit nime vaja ei ole Me ju Copy Basisime. Kogu asja on ju. Paneme plöaki maha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil olemas nagu kuhugi, kuhu andmeid salvestada Ja See peakski meie kõige esimene tegevus olema, et
Õpetaja: võtame selle saadud vastuse, mis tuleb sellest error responsest. See data.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlesin, kõik asjad ette, onju? Et paneme. Paneme selle siia sisse, elame ja siis toimetame edaspidi juba edasi. Sellega
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: Olen siin responses. Mis ma siis kirjutan, Siis Error response võrdub.
Õpetaja: Aga ei ole Error Punkt Data. Sellepärast Error on Grammi võrra Tema sees. On veel eraldi response ja siis tuleb Data. Kahjuks ta on Niukene. Noh, Niukene. Noh, ta on nagu suurem elukas. Ütleme niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil kogu see sisu on seal olemas. No nüüd me saame proovida isegi seda ka, Kui tahaks kiirelt
Õpetaja: Ee, proovida.
Õpetaja: Teen korra rakenduse lahti. Vaatan data bloki. Vaatan siis just on juurde tulnud. Hetkel on seal tühjus. Valin Pärnu
Õpetaja: korra klikin mujale. Vaata ja klikin tagasi. Siis ta niiöelda uuesti joonistab tuli vastus
Õpetaja: No Network I alt saaks ka vaadata, et see sõnum lendas ja tuli siuke vastus.
Õpetaja: Me teame, et ee. Selline asi seal on, on ju Meie missioon on seda, et võta Errori enda küljest. Error punkt response küljest staatus vaadata. Kas see on nelisada neli ja selle sama sõnumi Error koodist. Kas on väärtust? No location fund
Õpetaja: Kui need tingimused klapivad, siis me teame, et on selline olukord, et on vaja siis ee Kuvada kasutajale siin üleval Alerti.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: no läheme siis selle metoodikaga, et kui kui jääme kuskil seisma, lähme toimetame korra kõrval muid, asju praegu saab ühtteist ära teha. Millest alustan?
Õpetaja: Muidugi mingi tingimuse kontroll, onju? Meil on mingi sündmus. Sinna on ju, et me tahame vaadata mingeid andmeid.
Õpetaja: Me alustame siis võibolla sellest. Ee status koodist. Selle saab ka error Response küljest kätte.
Õpetaja: Aga seal on omakorda blokk Staatus, mis annab meile Selle Võibolla tasub siin teha keha kohe. Ära
Õpetaja: lüüa siia alla. Vaata, onju, et mingi normaalne asi on.
Õpetaja: Kood ei ole kohe katki igal Pool punane.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ütlengi. Error.
Õpetaja: Pilt on sellele, mis meile tuli. Internetist. Ma ütlen internetist. Ma mõtlen serverit, error, Ee, on see punkt
Õpetaja: Ja siit staatus S Täh paneb ära. Mis see staatus, mis selle tüübiga on?
Õpetaja: Noh, täpselt et kui meil nüüd tuleb võrdlus, siis me Julgeme ju teha niimoodi julgelt kolme võrdusmärki
Õpetaja: ja panna siia Noh, taaskis öeldi, et see on nelisada. Neli, nelisada neli töötaks praegu mõlemad ideaalselt idee järgi.
Õpetaja: Aga kui paneks niimoodi, siis enam ei töötaks Niimoodi siis töötaks on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Aga see on. See oli ainult esimene pool
Õpetaja: Teist poolt on ka vaja vaadata, et. Ee, Kas Kui pärnult vaadata seda,
Õpetaja: siis on vaja järgmisena vaadata küljest error koodi, et kas see võrdub. No location found Ee sneakase all, Caps.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas ma saan lisatingimusi panna? Seifi sisse?
Õpetaja: Kaks fändi. Jah, nüüd juba seekord. Meil on Selleks hetkeks on kogu sisu
Õpetaja: Saame ilusti selle kaudu toimetada. Mudel on meil olemas Dis punkt error, respons, punkt.
Õpetaja: Väga suur nii edasi ja Nüüd tuleb see string. Ee no location found no alakriips location
Õpetaja: found. Ma varasemalt mainisin ka seda, et klassikaliselt tegelikult seda erorit sellisel kujul üldse Ei, tehtaks.
Õpetaja: Tuleb tühi. Massiiv, Palun väga. Te mis tahad Sellega ei leidnud. Ja Sealt pealt saab. Kogeda kõike.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on siis Põhimõtteliselt oleks vaja. No praegu lihtsalt Alerdi teha.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt alert.
Õpetaja: Me anname näiteks selle sisuks praegult. Selle sama sõnumi, mis sealt tuleb,
Õpetaja: Ee, mis Siit tuleb Refresh I seal.
Õpetaja: No, tuli lihtsalt talle ette. Aga ma mõtlesin, seda et ee, teeme niimoodi, et ta lihtsalt kuvab seda alerti,
Õpetaja: Mis ma siis siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No kus on kogu meie sisse tulnud? Niiöelda ee, niiöelda. Errori vastus.
Õpetaja: This are response punkt message.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui nüüd juba tulla. Siia teha. Refresh. Panna sellised Korra kinni. Pole Vajagi enam. Valin Ee Tartu. Kõik on hästi, Valin Pärnu
Õpetaja: Ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga nüüd on missioon, on see, et ee, aga tahaks niimoodi et ta näitab seda selles punases kastis. Ja näiteks, ma ei tea tabeli üleval või kuskil midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Mis mõte ta on?
Õpetaja: Mhm, mis see komponendi nimi oli?
Õpetaja: Kui tahaks vaadata, siis ta on siin komponentide all. Air Danger on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me vaatame selle faili nime,
Õpetaja: nüüd on, ee. Esimest korda meil Niukene mõnus taaskasutatavus on ju Võime minna kohe. Julgelt
Õpetaja: Ee. Kuhugi, kus me soovime näidata. No näiteks. Võibolla siis näitab Ma ei tea selle pangaautomaatide üleval või all. Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Paneme siia pangaautomaadi veel alla.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Ja Kui hakata kirjutama suurte tähtedega. A d
Õpetaja: pakub mulle komponenti noole alla. Muidugi ei pane noolt alla, siis ta mõtleb, et ma tahan teha niukest rohel. Saab, valib ja vahel ei vali. Parem on noolega alla, minna, Nüüd tema ei tea. Vaata, et kas me tahame seda komponenti kahe tag iga või ühe tag iga. Kui me tahame teha ühe tag I. Kas me paneme lihtsalt selle kaldkriipsu ära? Ja ta teeb ülejäänud näpuga.
Õpetaja: Mhm kunagi hiljem kui vaatame madalid ja slotte ja igasuguseid muid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis. Ee. Siis. Me tahame ka, et aeg. Iga hetkel tahame aega.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kontrolltühik näitab seda ka, et ee,
Õpetaja: Temal on tegelikult Niisugune Props nagu error. Message. Teda saab kirjutada kahel viisil. Camel Case ja kebab Case, me kindlalt eelistame seda teist.
Õpetaja: Error messet on esialgu Ma panen Aa ja vaatan, kas tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aa, ahah. Märkasime midagi, mis siin on.
Õpetaja: Võtab kogu selle laiuse endale ära, et natukene on. Craisi onju?
Õpetaja: Võibolla tuleme siis siia ülesse ja piirame seda natukene, et ei oleks nii suur. See pangaautomaadidega. Kogu asju hoiab keskele niikuinii hetkeseisuga vähemalt
Õpetaja: Et Siis me võime öelda, et teeme näiteks mingi kolm ja viis. Äkki vä.
Õpetaja: No idee järgi. Justkui sobib. Aga mis paigast ära läks või? No mis ei olnudki paigas? Tegelikult,
Õpetaja: ta on Justify start. Vaata, on ju? Kuna see kogu see krempel
Õpetaja: on sees, siis siin on See koht, kus me saame öelda seda, et.
Õpetaja: Ee, tee te lihtsamaks. Ma. Ma ei paneks seda lõppu. Ma ütleks selle Marchin Botom Nelja sinna lõppu. Siia kirjutad, Justify?
Õpetaja: Ta võtab seal paremal. Pool on ka näha.
Õpetaja: Vajutate selle, Siis vaatame, et nagu, Noh, mingi enamvähem käib ka,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on mure, on see, et error message niiöelda on staatiliselt
Õpetaja: lihtsalt tekst. Me tahame muuta selle dünaamiliseks, mis meile on vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Me ei saa teha niimoodi, et iga kord hakkab näitama. Aa, D või isegi täida kõik. Täida kõik väljad, et ee, sellist pangaautomaati ei ole, Noh, ta. Ju stabiilselt koguaeg. Siis ju näitaks. Kui sisu on. Vaata, siis ta ju näitab. Mäletate, ma olen selle korra
Õpetaja: siin. Oli templeid meil tehtud niimoodi, et kui error message, kui Propsiga tuleb midagi sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui ei ole tühi, siis seda Tv I näidatakse,
Õpetaja: Kui on tühi, siis ei näidata.
Õpetaja: No tagasi, mis meil on vaja? Teha? Vaata, et me ei saa jätta, niimoodi et meil on staatiline tekst. See pole See koht
Õpetaja: Davai Kool on sinna ette justkui viitab siis millele?
Õpetaja: Jah, praegu viitab sellele Nüüd, et on mingi muutujad. Tahame kirjutada, siis hoopis Või otseväärtus saab ka olla.
Õpetaja: Aga siis on nagu küsimus, et kontol tühik, Et mis, Ee, asju ta pakub mulle kolm
Õpetaja: noh, seda saaks ka teha. Seda saaks ka teha, et ma ütlen, et Err spons, Aga Rr Respons on ju kogu objekt. Kogu objekt on message ja Error kood on ju
Õpetaja: Siin oleks. Ee, mis nüüd juhtus?
Õpetaja: Siin lihtsalt midagi ei juhtunud. Veel. Ee, jah. Saaks teha niimoodi. Ka, Vaata põhimõtteliselt, et me ehitame nagu selle jälgimise. Näiteks selle sõnumi peale.
Õpetaja: Aga ma pakun, et see on natukene libe tee,
Õpetaja: sest et seda peab ka siis ühtlasi reset Ima.
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Peab ju ütlema Error Response punkt. Message. Tee ta tühjaks ja nii edasi. Pigem on nagu see, et Siin võiks olla eraldi muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kas siin on mingid muutused, mis meile sobib?
Õpetaja: Mida tohiks kasutada No miks me seda City Id City Id pealt. Ee, kuva. Valitakse, et mis siia tuleb.
Õpetaja: Pigem on, et see, et ei olegi, et oleks mõistlik et, meil oleks üks eraldi muutuja Mis puhtalt manageerib seda asja, et,
Õpetaja: ee, juhul kui meil on viga
Õpetaja: seda sisu, kuvatakse, et praegu meil on siin alerta ero response message, et me lihtsalt võtame kogu vastusest tulnud ühe osa sisust ja lihtsalt viskasime nagu Javascripti Alerti, onju Siin on see sama mure, Vaata, et Sul on see message olemas. Mis sa taga edasi teed?
Õpetaja: Kuna me tahame panna reageerima ta.
Õpetaja: Ee, niiöelda siis. Ee. Et visuaalselt tuleks. See Kõige Mõistlikum oleks siin teha täiesti eraldi üks Uus muutuja
Õpetaja: nagu, ta oli meil noh. Vaatame, korra loo kinni loo. Kinnis Oli ka sama Lähenemine ju vaatan
Õpetaja: oli meil error message ja ta reageeris. Ee, kui ma lähen template otsima, näed, siis ta oli seotud
Õpetaja: selle retangeriga Sama asja tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis siia.
Õpetaja: Error message.
Õpetaja: Kool on algväärtus. On tal.
Õpetaja: Tal on alväärkatus
Õpetaja: tühistreening. Nii kuna meil on niukene reaktiivsuse asi. Ehitatud. Vaata, et vältida igasuguseid pugisid, et. No tegelikult teeme selle pugi ära. Siis pärast näitan. Vaata seda, on ju? Teeme lihtsalt praegu lõpuni, Nüüd, et nüüd on meil olemas see muutuja.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me soovime kahes kohas ta temaga toimetada ühes kohas. Me soovime kuvada selle sisu Template osas teises kohas. Me soovime seda väärtustada selle sõnumiga, mis backendist tuleb, On ju
Õpetaja: ehk siis, kui me läheme siia Aa Visuaali poole, Siis me ütleme. Terror message.
Õpetaja: See alert Danger saab oma sisu muutujalt.
Õpetaja: Error. Message Hetkel on ta kogu aeg tühine, et ta paneb siit Jebed Iee minema.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me läheme siis programmiliselt sinna kohta, kus me just ennem toimetasime, et kui staatus on nelisada neli ja error Response error Kood on No location found Siis mis me tahame siin teha?
Õpetaja: Tahame sellest error responsi. Message I sisu võtta.
Õpetaja: This euro message Punkt Message. Tahame seda sisu võtta ja panna selle elama siia sisse,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui see sisu muutub, renderdatakse jälle visuaal uuesti ja näidatakse Valeriti on nii?
Õpetaja: Siia, siis kirjutan
Õpetaja: edasi.
Õpetaja: Mis
Õpetaja: viis punkti pealt kirjutada, siis Läheb kuidagi imelikuks. Okei, anname teile uue sisu
Õpetaja: et see ongi See, et sa kogu aeg puudutad neid. Ee, niiöelda neid silte, et kas sa saada informatsiooni
Õpetaja: või anda sinna Uus informatsioon võrdusmärk annab, on ju, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: nüüd on see, et me anname üle ja automaatselt peaks olema meil tulemas, et kui ma proovin nagu Tallinn
Õpetaja: Tartu pärnu.
Õpetaja: Okei, pärnu tuli. Aga mis nüüd halvasti on, Tartu?
Õpetaja: Et eelmine asi jääb ikka meelde. Tal.
Õpetaja: Miks sellepärast, et vastab tõele, et Kogu see linn renderdatakse Locations objekti pealt, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga tema sisu koodi tasandil ei ole nüüd kuidagi muutunud,
Õpetaja: Ega need ega nende Niiöelda teiste muutujate sisu kuidagi üldse siin automaatselt. Selles mõttes ju ei muutu, Vaid me peame ise programmeerima. Järelikult kui me tahame nüüd seda Ee, olukorda niiöelda manageerida.
Õpetaja: Meil on mitu lahendust. Vaata, üks variant on. Me võime peita kogu linna kogu selle tabeli ära.
Õpetaja: Me võime uuendada Seda massiivi tühja massiiviga jäävad nagu need headerid. Aga süsi sisu on tühi, et siin on nagu visua. Siin on nagu, lihtsalt nagu kasutaja, Niiöelda kasutaja kogemuse. Nagu küsimus, et kuidas me nagu sooviksime.
Õpetaja: Mina küsin teilt. Vaata, kuidas te soovite, et nüüd, mis nägema peab või kuidas see olema. Peab.
Õpetaja: Mis te tahate
Õpetaja: ülikoolis,
Õpetaja: et jääb lihtsalt sisu tühjaks. Jah, no tundub mõistlik vaata. Et, ei leidnud midagi ja väikene vihje Vaata, et miks sa midagi ei näe, onju?
Õpetaja: No Davai. Siis on nagu see, et me siin selles kohas, kus me seda ee niiöelda Errorit näitame
Õpetaja: siis praegult. Taustal ikka. See on täpselt ee. Selline nagu ta viimane kord, oli. Kui andmed ära toodi,
Õpetaja: kõik, mis me peame, tegema. On, See et me peame talle andma
Õpetaja: tühja massiivi Ja siis pole ühtegi elementi, millega tsükeldada Järelikult ühte kiri ta ei tule, siis Läheme siia alla
Õpetaja: uuel real, mis ma võiksin kirjutada?
Õpetaja: Esimene pool on teada. Soovime mingisugusele asjale uut sisu anda.
Õpetaja: Küsimus ja sest Locations pealt joonistatakse. Tabel vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Kuidas annad veel uue sisu võrdusmärgiga?
Õpetaja: Annan talle tühja massiivi, palun väga. See On samamoodi nagu loome uue objeki tühi objekt.
Õpetaja: See on loome uue raie objekti.
Õpetaja: Aga ta on tühi.
Õpetaja: Ma ise saaksin panna objekti. Kui ma tahaks, teen mingi objekti. Ma annan mingi välja. Nime. Annan talle mingi väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saab ka. Vaata, see loob Harra ja objekti, Aga see on tühi, Järelikult For loop,
Õpetaja: ma Proovin ka, et Tartu kas jääb Tartu enam ette, kui panen pärnu, läks minema.
Õpetaja: Noh, visuaal on niuke küsitav. Näeb nagu välja aga We Dont Care.
Õpetaja: See on ka kuidagi üldse liiga lai Ma tõmbaks. Selle ee. Selle tabeli. Kus on tabel?
Õpetaja: Teeks ka hästi natukene väiksemaks. See on minu meelest natuke suur.
Õpetaja: Mina ei tea, Kolm, neli. Vaatame korra.
Õpetaja: Kolm. Neli on nagu kuidagi väga väike.
Õpetaja: Noh, info kuvab ära, võibolla Kolm, viis.
Õpetaja: Nii. Mis nüüd on see. Et kuna kõik asjad ei täidagi tervet ekraani ära, on ju? Siis on nad, saame aru et mõttes on kõik Sisu nihkes vasakule.
Õpetaja: Me peame üles otsima. Kus on see rohu? Siin
Õpetaja: Siin saame öelda samamoodi. Justify Content Center.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma Ei tea, käib ka.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi tuleb järgi? Ei tule Davai.
Õpetaja: Ee, tulge järgi kohe, kui push tuleb. Ära. Ee, sest et nüüd on Viimane osa. See on nagu suht Niukene tšillipilli
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ahah, täpselt õige. Aa, Sellepärast, et kui ma selle vea,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen pärnu, siis saab Endale sisuprogrammiliselt saab.
Õpetaja: Noh, panen tagasi kõik linnad või Tallinn Tartu.
Õpetaja: Mitte kunagi enam uuesti. Err Message ei saa sisu.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seda lihtsam on teha, on see, et iga Jumala kord, kui laetakse tabel onju, siis võiks alguses
Õpetaja: resetida selle ee error message i sisu tühjaks ringiks
Õpetaja: Ehk kui just see olukord produc Ib seda probleemi, et kui keegi valib niiöelda sisendiks, ma ei tea Pärnu ei leita midagi. Siit tuleb See error,
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see meetod. Ee, mis meil käivitab linnade äratoomise, on see õige, koht
Õpetaja: et seda ei ole mõtet resetida kuidagi hiljem mingi nupuvahetusega, vaid ennem kui üldse tabeliandmeid ära toome. Iga kord vaikeseis on see, et viga pole,
Õpetaja: aga selles see mõte ongi,
Õpetaja: Ei, vot See ongi see, et kui mina valisin pärnu ja sain vea, on viga, on ju? Kui kujutame ette, et ma tegelikult oleks pidanud siia tulema ka sellise olukorraga, et ma olen kõik linnad peal. Kui ma valin pärnu, siis enne, kui me ee niiöelda hakkame andmeid ära tooma, Me kaotame selle Errori ära, sest me ei tea, kas tuleb error või mitte, aga algseis on see, et seda ei ole on ju,
Õpetaja: on veelgi. Täpsem on? Nüüd, kus sa tahad, on, kujutage ette, et iga kord, kui vajutad mingi uue linna, resetime ära põmm, kadus ära. Kas tuli viga? Ei tulnud viga? Järelikult ei näita.
Õpetaja: Jah, no siis otsime nagu ülesse. Kus see scriptis? Meil on?
Õpetaja: Gat Locations Iga nupu Vajutuse peale võiks öelda.
Õpetaja: This Punkt, mis? Ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Error Message edasi pöördub tühistrering.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et iga kord, kui minnakse andmeid ära tooma, sest siin saab Serror tekkida. On ju siin.
Õpetaja: Algseis on see, et ei ole Error, et. No nüüd on nüüd on see, Ta Kaob järgmise nupu vajutusega ära, on? Ju
Õpetaja: Noh, oleks ka võimalik teha niimoodi, et see läheb sealt mingi paari sekundi pärast ise ära. No See on huvi, Vaata, onju, et, noh, näidatakse teadet või pakutakse risti.
Õpetaja: No pane kinni. Vaata, häirib mind. See on ju aga vahet pole, Isegi kui need variandid on olemas, siis mida me kindlalt tahame, on see, et kui inimene nüüd mingit uut asja vajutab, siis ta läheb kindlate eest ära, et on meil pärnu ja leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. Valin Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Noh, viga ei tulnud.
Õpetaja: Olin uuesti Pärnu tuleb uuesti. No nagu Lollikindel.
Õpetaja: See on kõige lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et, noh, saaks teha niimoodi, et siia tuleb väike ristikene, näiteks ja ristikesest saad kinni panna, see Pole mingi probleem, Lihtsalt on visuaalne rist, millele on peatud Click Event,
Õpetaja: mis käivitab meetodi või otse seal, samas kohe ütleb, et ee läheb tühjaks. Noh, ta kaob ära. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Vot seda saaks ka teha, kui tahaks.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ikka edasi, ikka edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd On Siis see olukord, et. Ee. Kas ma komit I tegin? Vaata, hakkasime tegema. Kas saite järgi või Keegi on ikka veel maas Käsi Vist Ei,
Õpetaja: nüüd on see osa. Kus me siis tahaks võtta selle tabeli osa?
Õpetaja: Ja teades seda eraldi komponenti, seal oli ju nimi mingi Locations või Stable? Vist oli.
Õpetaja: Ee, kumb oli? Ma ei mäleta enam Pigem Location Stable öeldi, et tee eraldi komponent.
Õpetaja: Location Stabel on nii Kas keegi Chirat ka üldse ise on vaadanud? Või vaatad lihtsalt minu ekraanilt.
Õpetaja: Te saate ise nagu kõrvale panna, et kui tahate midagi lugeda Või vaadata või kodus vaadata, onju? Ee, rahulikult järgi, et mis seal kirjas on? Ee, siis siin oleks kõige mõistlikum niimoodi et, tõmmata see asi korra niimoodi kokku
Õpetaja: ja sellest asjast võiks teha eraldi komponendi. Nüüd me teame, et pirni abil on seda võimalik ka teha. Jõuab õige Valikuni alt. Enter
Õpetaja: Ekstract View komponent.
Õpetaja: Mm, ma teen korra selle kommitti ära, lihtsalt et ma saaksin kiirelt. Ma ei viitsi siin kontra setitada Ja nii edasi. Ma teen korra komiti ära. No kui keegi tahab, siis saab tegelikult kasutada seda võimalust tulla ka järgi, aga ma mõte On See kommitt? On tegelikult pigem mulle iseendale hetkel. Siin.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: vaadake, mis juhtub. Ee, kuidas see asi tuleb? Kui milline saab olema see Komponent ja Propside Ja mingi muude asja teema juhul,
Õpetaja: kui siin on ainult kasutuses databloki muutujad hetkel Tegelikult ainukene asi, mida ta päriselt vajab Ja Millest mi? Ütleme niimoodi? Et mõelge sellele asjale niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et kui sina viiksid selle koodi siit ära, vaata, onju siis, millele Tal on vaja ligipääsu, mis asub siin failis. No see on ju meil siin. Failis on nii
Õpetaja: seda ta sinna kaasa ei vii. Järelikult ta peab Propsi tegema.
Õpetaja: Transaction types on tegelikult location I küljes. Location on Locationsi küljes ainukene niiöelda võõrkeha, ee, mis siin on ainukene viide üldse, nagu Ma võin mingi suvalisse kohta panna. Veel midagi. Ma ei tea, siia linna juurde. Panen näiteks.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, City Id Blok. City Id. Näiteks viitan City Id Le.
Õpetaja: Näiteks,
Õpetaja: kui ma praegult teeks selles komponendi. Ärge praegu korra kaasa tehke. Vaid lihtsalt korra. Vaadake, siis on visuaalselt juba näha, mismoodi ta seda tahab teha?
Õpetaja: Mitme mitme propsiga. Ta soovib teha. Siin City Id ja Locations on nii
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et mõlemad mõlem Mõlemad on sildikesed, mis on meie datablokis. Ja kui me neile viitame. Aga see informatsioon hakkab olema teises failis Vaata see ainukene moodus, kuidas seda informatsiooni sinna edasi kanda on läbi Propside. Noh, Kosk voolab alla,
Õpetaja: kui ma võtan praegult selle City Id siit ära, on ju
Õpetaja: kui Ma nüüd teen sellest ee samast elemendist.
Õpetaja: Teine korra samamoodi. Niimoodi, et tõmbad nad kokku, On lihtsam
Õpetaja: Control Ee, Ütlen nüüd, Ta tahab ainult niukest asja teha. Kus Locations antakse. Kaasa Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on päris hea, aga ma panen lihtsalt suvalisse kohta mingi klikk event I külge. Ma ei tea, ükstpuha kui ma panen selle.
Õpetaja: Ee, see vist saab. Ma otsin mingi tavalise Dv. I. Otsin selle näiteks Mina Panen siin. Ät Click
Õpetaja: ja ütlen, et ee. Kui sa klikid siia peale, siis käivita meetod. Ma ei tea, Get locations Vahet pole
Õpetaja: kui Ma nüüd nüüd on sama olukord aga natukene nagu teistmoodi. Ma viitan mingisugusele meetodile, mis on siin Atm S. View
Õpetaja: Methods blokis, on nii? No Ta ei saa kuidagi maagiliselt seda kaasa võtta.
Õpetaja: Mis ta siis teeb? Siis ta teeb tehnilise lahenduse, mis töötab, aga oleks väga rõve asi Millest aru saada.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan korra uuesti. Kus see tee peal hakkab? Siin
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et tee sellest Ee, voekomponeet.
Õpetaja: Siis, mis ta nüüd teeb. Näete, et ta teeb niukse propsi nagu Get Locations,
Õpetaja: mis viitab sellele meetodile, mis asub siin klassis,
Õpetaja: aga see ei olnud mingi ülisegadust Tekitav nagu sündaks. Ei ole väga lihtne. Ma korra võin selle valmis teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on New Component ja minna sinna vaatama.
Õpetaja: Ma korra Proovin uuesti.
Õpetaja: Kus tal jääb siis selline nimi
Õpetaja: Näete? Nüüd on niimoodi, et Kus see klikk Event on? Otsime ülesse. Ma tegin kuskile Dv. Siin
Õpetaja: Click Event käivitab Get Locations I Mis on kuskil Siin Failis Siis
Õpetaja: Locations on? Tegelikult Propsina Props tagasi siia ja see siis siin käivitab selle meetodi. See on üril nagu virvarr. Vaata, Kuidas, see asi nüüd toimib.
Õpetaja: Pigem ei ole seda vaja Get. Locations kuulubki. Ei pea mitte midagi sellest teadma.
Õpetaja: Aga kui Ta peab ka nagu teadma, et käivitab mingi tegevuse? No siis me teeme sinna, mitte Event I
Õpetaja: mis Käivitub kliki peale ja siin üleval ikkagi toimetame.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui te teete endale mingi selle põhja, teete kuskil seal projektis valmis
Õpetaja: ja te Hakkate teile Plaan on teha asjad erinevateks faili komponentideks. Taaskasutus, koodiloetus. Mis iganes põhjusel vahet pole,
Õpetaja: kui teil see on plaanis,
Õpetaja: Ee, siis senimaani On Fine seal toimetada, kuni te hakkate juurde lisama. Mingisuguseid meetode käivitamisi. Seda on pärast väga tüütu ekstraktide ümber tõsta ja teha see ei Vääri küünlaid. See on see koht, kus te tõmmate pidurit mõtlete? Oot oot,
Õpetaja: ma hakkan siin. Ee, selles asjas klikiga mingid meetodid välja kutsuma, Mis siin. On, ma seda praegult ei tee? Ma ekstraktin. Kõigepealt need visuaalsed asjad eraldi komponentideks ja siis programmeerin edasi, vaata nii nagu vaja,
Õpetaja: Sest et te siis juba lähete programmeerima ju teise faili. Esialgu vähemalt see. See komponent, mis te loote.
Õpetaja: No sihukene näide. Ee, ma teen Praegult selle. Rolback I
Õpetaja: kustutas seda komponenti ära. Jumal, tema ka.
Õpetaja: Nii Ee, Teeme siis meie asja selle puhtalt.
Õpetaja: Meil on ainult siin need, mis on vaja ja siin midagi keerulist polegi vaid Enter.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on lihtsalt nimi panna nimi pidi olema Location Stable.
Õpetaja: Mida sa kirjutada siin Peable niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kas tundub loogiline? Nüüd on Location Stable komponent. Aa, ärme unusta ära, et kuhu ta seda teeb? Faili Location Stable Voed loob selle sama faili kõrvale, kus me selle koodi just ekstractisime. Ehk siis ta on seal samas kaustas, kus on. Vaatame, kas on nii
Õpetaja: rohelisega Markeeritud kit Vär värvib siin. Meile, onju uus fail.
Õpetaja: Tõstame selle komponents alla lihtlabane. Kas keegi kasutab ka puutepatja
Õpetaja: progemisel. Ee, läpaka. Jumal tänatud Hiirega on väga mõnus niukseid asju teha. Mingil puute padjal. Kuskil siin sõrm natukene vääratab, läheb. Jumal teab, kuhu arendava tööriist on hiir ta on meie lemmik sõber.
Õpetaja: See on nagu. See on nagu armastus oma niiöelda kaaslase vastu. Vaata, et see on Niukene.
Õpetaja: No paneme siia. No Mingi hetk tõstame neid ka veits paika Siin praegu. See asi ei ole veel nii kriitiline, et siin midagi tõsta.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd, ega tegelikult Midagi ei muutunudki otseselt. Ta on puhtalt kuvatav objekt. Kui te võtate selle värgi. Ka. Vaata, siin on nagu nii elementaarne näide, nagu sellest.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil on Niukene.
Õpetaja: Näete siin Tegelikult see alumine joonis, mis tegelikult printer on üli halvasti printinud.
Õpetaja: Ee, see mitt. Vaata, siin on Lausa nagu näidatud. Vaata, et andmed päri. Vaadake seda pilti. Just paremal pool et seal on mingi päringuga päritakse andmed mis voolavad kuskile tabelisse. Sisse meil tegelikult nii ongi, on ju? Ta on ainult kuvatav. Ja isegi hiljem, kui teil tulevad mingid likvendid külge
Õpetaja: mingi kliki variant on, See, et mine üldse kuskile teisele vaatajale. Täitsa chill seal programmeerid ära. Ja kui on mingisugune tegevus, millest pärend, peab midagi teadma. Noh, siis Tee mitte vendi. Vaata, mõtled välja, mis siin juhtus ja mis peab tegema hakkama Ja ongi kõik. Pole mitte midagi keerulist.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatame korra Siis task I üle. Aga minu meelest on see küll nagu korra. Nüüd, peale Scroll Ides viga. Näitame
Õpetaja: kõiki asju, saab kuvada Mulle tundub, et me oleme sellega.
Õpetaja: Ta on just.
Õpetaja: Jah, pole siin nagu. Midagi.
Õpetaja: Aa, Davai. Väga hea. Siis. Ee. Teeme Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: nii. Hoiame need Failid Comey Time Push.
Õpetaja: Pluss pluss
Õpetaja: Push Otseselt ei pea ära ootama. Kui mitte on juba tehtud, vahetame haru, kui ta selle ära lükkab,
Õpetaja: Mina Olen oma õpetaja peale Tee mingi oma nime peale.
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on nüüd Merch Ida tehtud töö teeb kümnest
Õpetaja: õpetajasse see. On mersi kohal Peab vaatama teeb. Kümme into master hakata teil projektides olema
Õpetaja: projekt aa. By the way kui te. Teete projekte teil ei. Ole vaja taas ka teha.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, teil on vaja taas kä teha, kui te teete Ai ka niiöelda arendust. Aga seda te teete. Projekti sees neid taas kä, Nagu, et tema nagu mõistaks, mida on vaja teha. Aga teil ei ole vaja nagu planeerimise käigus kulutada aega, et teha mingeid aske või Asju, mis on teie dokumentatsioon.
Õpetaja: Olen rääkinud, mis on teie dokumentatsioon? Saab olema
Õpetaja: švagger. Saab olema dokumentatsioon. Selles mõttes, et teenused, mis teil on juba tehtud. Peegeldus
Õpetaja: Ee, Teil ei olegi mõtet mingit stoplaid. Jumal teab mingit muud tööriista kasutada, et teha endale Niukene appi teenuste kokkulepe, Teil Saab olema üks teine asi, mis on kogu teie dokumentatsioon,
Õpetaja: katab kõik nurgad. Ära.
Õpetaja: Voodi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Koodibaasi ei saa olla, kui te alles planeerite,
Õpetaja: Marko.
Õpetaja: Marta on. Saab olema see, et aega toimetada
Õpetaja: teedokumentatsioon saab olema teine. Teie. See mokk veebilehekül
Õpetaja: See katab kõik ära nagu vaata onju, Et, Ee, selles mõttes Teilataaske polegi vaja.
Õpetaja: Te panete kogu info lihtsalt sinna ei ole, õigus? Või Mingi oma paikkonna
Õpetaja: ja mingeid tekstidokumente võib ikka teha, Nagu, et, noh, paned kirja nagu mingi punktide kaupa, et teeme selle tolle? Ee, jah, sest et seda sa sinna eskiisi peale Järjekorda ei pane. See selles osas on õigus. Jah, seda tavaliselt kõik teevad. Ka Teevad mingi Google tops mingi faili vaata ja.
Õpetaja: Ja nagu Mõtlevad nagu ära.
Õpetaja: Ja et, ee, jah. Ütleme siis. Selles mõttes on natukene. On mõistlik küll teha noh. Eks, ta natukene kipub olema muidugi. Niimoodi. Vaata nii nagu sa seda mopp veebilehekülge teed. Ee, Oleneb kui väike või Kui suur see infosüsteem teil saab olema, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja Kui kui laiali ja harguvalt saab olla. Flow. Vaata niipea kui sisse logid, kuhu sa kõik minna saad? Vaata, et, noh, kui sul on Nagu niukse lihtsam. Need, kus saab ainult paari kohta minna. Siis see kandida Flow ongi, niimoodi, et, noh, sisse logimine on vaja teha
Õpetaja: kuhugi liigud. Ja sealt saab natuke edasi minna ja nii edasi. On ju, et seal tööde järjekord on nagu ka enda, nagu juba sisse kirjutatud. Aga kui on juba natukenegi rohkem mingit funktsionaalsust Ja asja. Siis on küll see, et mis järjekorras neid asju teeme
Õpetaja: ja seal on hästi tähtis seda, et. Ee. No ma hästi natuke räägin ette. Vaata teises pooles nagu veits. Korra hinge tõmmata. Ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes te oma teenuseid peaksite tegema sellises järjekorras. Kui te mõtlete nagu Ee toimingutele, siis teid huvitavad. Kõigepealt
Õpetaja: on nagu need, millele te peate panema rõhku, igasugused Update Liitasjad on sekundaarsed, kui mis annab süsteemile kõige rohkem väärtust. Mingisugune sisu. Mida te näete. Ee, sisu. Loomulikult tuleb põhimõtteliselt andmebaasistega võimalik andmeid tekitada. Pole mingit probleemi,
Õpetaja: et, ee, üsna palju saaks. Tegelikult ee riidegevustega juba väga, palju näidata. Süsteemi Näen siin asju ja mida iganes,
Õpetaja: aga Kui sul on mingid pildid ja asjad, siis tekib kohe stopp. Vaata peale, et neid nagu enam script idega väga tšilli pildi pole teha, Ehk Siis minu mõte on niimoodi, et te alati panustate niimoodi, et te proovite teha rohkem neid asju, mis kõik lisavad andmeid,
Õpetaja: süsteemi, postegevused, Ee, ja siis, ee. Siis riitegevused, et kui sa kuvad mingisuguseid andmeid ja selle jaoks on mingisugune lehekülg, kus saab tekitada uusi andmeid, süsteeme saab lisada andmeid, siis pigem, nagu et häkkida Kõigepealt neid.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete selle asja valmis, siis te saate väga mugavalt juba oma süsteemiandmeid lisada, kasutades seda sama liidest. Vaata, millega nii öelda. Valmis progate.
Õpetaja: Ja loomulikult riid on selleks, et midagi nagu inimestele, nagu näidata, et kõik, need kuvamise asjad ära teha. Ja ma ütlengi, et siis see update Liit on Niukene lõpus juba natukene tilulilu, selles mõttes, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ta ei oma nagu nii suurt tähtsust. Esiteks, kui on nagu olemas, siis eriti odavalt. Eliit loomulikult? Update, on natuke keerulisem. Võibolla keerulisem,
Õpetaja: lihtsalt ee, Järjekord oleks see miks? Sellepärast, et saab juba mängida?
Õpetaja: Mitte küll vanu andmeid. Vaata, kus on süsteemis olemas ja sa kuidagi eriti ta, aga Nagu printsiibis. Nagu et kui andmed tulevad juurde ja vähenevad,
Õpetaja: siis saab nii ka teha. Noh, see on vale asi, et visad mingid andmed, See on vigane. Kustutad ära. Teed uue kande. Noh, apteek,
Õpetaja: et ee, umbes niukses järjekorras hakata minema. Ja loomulikult muidugi on hea, kui panete mingi visiooni paika, et mis järjekorras? Ee, mis tundub teile nagu selle süsteemi juures kõige väärtuslikumad osad.
Õpetaja: Ee, et teil kõigil hakkab projektidesse, mis Ma nagu varakult kavatsen sisse nagu lasta teil planeerida, on see, et te mõtlete, nagu. Mida teil see infosüsteem teeb? Te otsustate iseenda jaoks ära. Mis on Mvp? Tähendab,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Nba hinnad on siin mingi Player miinimum vahepeal produkt.
Õpetaja: Ee, miinimum elujõuline nagu toode nagu mis omab nagu Mingit väärtust, Mep. Otsustate ära nagu mida te kõigepealt ründate. Mis Nagu on kogu selle süsteemi poolt nagu kõige väärtuslikum osa, onju? Teete seda Ja siis tuleb ikka mingi tilulilu värki ka. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee saab juurde teha et me planeerime töid. Niimoodi, Vaata et ee. Me peame kuidagi proovima niimoodi, et teil tiimil ee ei oleks liiga suurt taastet, et ei tekiks. See skoop ei läheks, Coop liiga suureks
Õpetaja: ei jõua ära teha. Lihtsalt vaata, siis võib jääda kuidagi niuke tunne, nagu asi jäi väga pooliklikuks, aga samas ei taha teistpidi. Ee, et kui projekt on Väga, väga väike. Ee, Siis on niimoodi, et kolme peale ragistate selle mingi paari päevaga, ära on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis on nagu see. Vaata, On ju, et siis planeerimise käigus saab juba mõelda, et kui tundub, et on natukene nagu vähe asju, vaata, siis saab alati mõelda juurde, Aga, noh, mõtleme juurde siia. Mingisugused Nice to nice to have Niiöelda mingid funktsionaalsused ja asjad on ju
Õpetaja: ee, ja siis on nagu, see, Et vähemalt planeerimise käigus me juba sellele mõtleme. Andmebaasi mudelis ka. Võibolla teeme selle osa ära ja siis pärast. Kui hakkab progemine pihta, siis Vastavalt ajale on mida võtta nagu. Vaata, et,
Õpetaja: ee. See on juba nagu varem välja mõeldud. Lihtsalt halb on nagu see. Vaata, kui. Kui Nagu üldse ei taha. Nagu panna. Nagu sellele. Nagu mingisugust ee, energiat ja mõtlemist. Niiöelda. Vaata, et mis nagu võiks veel olla, võibki juhtuda Niimoodi, et projekt ongi nii kitsas. On ju, et
Õpetaja: pärast kui tööd saavad otse ja hakkad siis midagi juurde mõtlema, siis nad on kuidagi Niuksed. Väga pastakasti nimetud. Nagu juurde tehtud asjad Ja kuidagi nagu ei haaku. Ja siis ongi võibolla nagu see, koht et vaata, äkki oleks sellele varem mõelnud, kas oleks valinud mingi teise projekti või oleks oluliselt rohkem aega mõelda. Vaata, mida veel võiks olla,
Õpetaja: et see on nagu Selles mõttes siuke õppeprojekt. Ee, asi. Ma vist ei viitsi ka rohkem teha. Selle me tegi. Panime lukku onju, juba Ja vastas jääb, onju Ee,
Õpetaja: mis ma veel nagu. Mis üldse on? Põhitoimingud peavad olemas olema, mis on nagu nõuded Ee kruutegevused peab süsteemis ära saada teha. Ühel Või teisel viisil. Ja teine asi on, mis on väga tähtis, et absoluutselt kõik ee, tiimiliikmed arendavad ee, vähemalt ühel või teisel hetkel ee mõlemat poolt. Nii front kui ka back.
Õpetaja: Ee, et see on nõue, et ei ole niimoodi, et ma olen see vend ja sa oled See frondi naine või või vastupidi, mis iganes
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et teil peab olema tiimiliikmetes piisavalt palju niiöelda seda ee, meeskonna tuge, et igasuguseid asju arutada. Väga raske on Fronti inimesel küsida. Abi. Oi, mul mingid asjad ei tööta. Ma ei saa aru, miks see midagi läheb valesti ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: Kuid rutiini liige Rutiiniliikmed on ainult terve aja. Seda ei oska mitte midagi nagu koos mõelda. Kui kõik teevad kõike kolm pead, On parem kui üks pea, On ju? Ee, et selles mõttes siis on juba nagu see juba teeb paremini. Ma lihtsalt kogemusest mäletan. Mingi
Õpetaja: Neljas grupp või viies grupp oli kaks tüüpi. Tegid. Packi tüdruk tegi Fronti. Ja, oi, kuidas oli Struggel ja minu, nagu, ee, niiöelda ressurss oli jagatud kõikide tiimide vahel kordamööda. Käidi. Aita, et, noh, piiratud onju Chat Shipidi D. Sellisel polnudki.
Õpetaja: Ee, et nagu kuskilt küsida ja siis Oli küll probleem, et nagu isegi oma tiimiliikmetega polnud võimalik midagi arvata.
Õpetaja: Palju suur viga.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis veel projektide kohta? Võibolla siis ee rääkida.
Õpetaja: Aega on. Ee. Jah, okei, ma mõtlen praegu. Ee, jah, ee. Projektidest saab veel rääkida küll. Ja küll,
Õpetaja: ee, Mingid juhendid on ka olemas, Mul see,
Õpetaja: mida erinevad on.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on ise allapoole.
Õpetaja: Sa korra kohe vaadata mis sa mõtled, Ostad?
Õpetaja: Mul on üks selline tunne, et korra see, kui see põleb niimoodi, et ma arvan, et sul on insert, on peal,
Õpetaja: Aga kas ta nüüd töötab korraks seal?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: oli Lihtne küsimus. Tuleb mingi põnev küsimus. Aga sa formuleerid Kuidas öelda, ühe liigutuse teen Ära või ütleme et selle algoritmiga aidata.
Õpetaja: Ee, varasemalt ma Tegin seda niimoodi, et isegi ei teadnud. Tavaliselt tegin seda reedel õhtul. Kui oled ära läinud, kavatsen teid ümber tõsta, et see, kus te Istusite, et Ega te nüüd ometi kuus nädalat, kolm, neli nädalat, nagu istun samade inimeste kõrval.
Õpetaja: Kõik saaks kõigega hängida ja natukene tutvuda Rohkem Sina peale, siis tõstan teid niiöelda ringi. Miks ma seda enam ei tee? Ühe grupiga? Ma tegin selle. Tõstsin sildid ümber. Esimene mingi inimene Tuli klassiruumi, vaatas, et huvitav koristaja on kõik nagu nime. Sildid,
Õpetaja: bussid ringi tagasi. Ma nagu reede õhtul, nagu omast ajast, aga lähevad ja Siis muidugi, Okei.
Õpetaja: Never. Agent,
Õpetaja: mul on selles mõttes. Ma üritan teha niimoodi, et need, kes ka enne tagapool istuvad, tulles natukene ettepoole, aga Eesmärk on see et ikkagi. Miksime nüüd. Nagu Ee, inimesi. Siis ma teen seda kuidagi niimoodi, et mul on esialgu esimesildil
Õpetaja: Ee, tooge kõike nimesi sildi. Tõsi, enda poole
Õpetaja: ongi, niimoodi, et ma näen neid
Õpetaja: selja tagant. Siis vä. Ei, ei, pange just vastupidi ja nii pigem lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis mul on minu saate kaasa aidata mõelda. Esimene. Asi on hästi lihtne. On see, et võtan keskmise. Noh, kui on, sul ei ole kedagi kõrvale, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan siit keskelt selle vähe
Õpetaja: ja ma tõstan siia ruumi taha ja vahetan nüüd kaks omavahel ära, aga see ei ole üldse nii lihtne nagu Kui te võiks mõelda, et
Õpetaja: jaa ja kaks kohta ongi mõju, on see ikka kadunud. Nüüd ma teen seletamist ma selle õiget pidi.
Õpetaja: Ja tegelikult kogemata kersti olaja keele sai ka seal nagu teisele poole, sest monitori pool on keeratud need ma Olen juba ära käinud. Ma olen kogu aeg mõelnud, et võiks teha siis väikse rakenduse. See ei oleks üldse keeruline. Ma olen kaks korda Tahaks Switchida. Vähemalt nii. Nüüd on need ära tehtud. Aa, nüüd on see. Vaadake
Õpetaja: hopsi ja hopsi.
Õpetaja: Nii, paneme õigetpidi.
Õpetaja: Nii, kuidas
Õpetaja: Aa ja Ja. Ja. Ja, no, okei, okei, okei, vot nüüd. Vaatame ära. Aga teeme siin niimoodi Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: niimoodi. Nii, Vähemalt keegi tuli ettepoole. Okei, ma Nüüd keskendun. Aju istub seal
Õpetaja: aju. Lihtsalt siin taga kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Ma just tõstsin siia. Vaata, on ju? Seda? Ei, ole mõtet.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme siis niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Praegu on uued inimesed. Nimed peaks olema, onju?
Õpetaja: Mis Ma veedan siin keskusega.
Õpetaja: No ise siin väga palju pole Nagu rahast nagu Lihtsalt üks liigub natukene teisele poole. Nii, nüüd on. Pole need äärmised kuidagi ära vahetada.
Õpetaja: Ma võin korra.
Õpetaja: Mina juba improviseerin. Nüüd juba läks arvesse. Liigud edasi?
Õpetaja: Jah, ma ei tea, No ma ei tea, saanud Jah, kuidas. Ma olen avatud ideedele
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: sinna. Raha poole pärast on Niimoodi, Vaata aga niimoodi on ka variant. Okei, ma ei tea nüüd. Ma olen juba poolel teel. Ega ma enam alguses muudame
Õpetaja: järgmises korras Oota, see on, mis on tagurpidi veel kaardi No kohe tõstame ümber.
Õpetaja: Okei? Tuleb see ees Saad selle kaardi ära võtida
Õpetaja: nii ja panna Lihtsalt koer ette. Kas need on kaks On koos Tahaks saada?
Õpetaja: Kus on samal ajal?
Õpetaja: Ei ole jah. Kuulge,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, ma lihtsalt huvitanud.
Õpetaja: Okei, saime ühele poole.
Õpetaja: Ee, te võite juba täna asju liigutada. Võibolla ongi. Parem. Teeme niimoodi. Et Ee, kohe. Sind tund saab läbi Niikuinii, et tõstke juba paika. Jah,
Õpetaja: oih, praegu tuli, aga.
Õpetaja: Aga sa oled mingi sellise asja peale, mis nagu ei vaja, nagu mingi nagu, Kus, on nagu päriselt? Vaata, nagu mingi probleem. Vaata, ma proovin korra produtseerida,
Õpetaja: Pakkuma midagi. Vaata, tal ei ole mingit viga. Vaata kollast krim Ei ole punast. Krimmi pole, et siis ta on nagu üritanud spetsiaalselt leida. Paku mulle konteksti järgi mingisuguseid tegevusi. Ma ei tea, sa mõtled,
Õpetaja: Vajad Kümme peale jah?
Õpetaja: Jah, käite, aega muide.
Õpetaja: Ei, vä okei.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, on severi See sama arvamus
Õpetaja: aga. Minul põhimõtteliselt vaata. Mul, on natuke See visuaalteen. Kus sa halu näe, Üldse vaja ei ole seda me.
Õpetaja: Vabandust,
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, selle selle. Vaata, Noored, nagu
Õpetaja: lõpuks selle sama nii, Ee, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Mina panen. Aa, panen kinni.
Õpetaja: Oi, ei, ole. On ikkagi hästi. Ma mõtlesin.